tuesday and that means it is the great
area with myself sarah garvey and the
lady lighting up youtube right now all
social medias
just pearly things
okay we today are going to be
piggybacking off the back of one of
pearl's videos actually um
is abortion a cop out that's what we're
gonna be speaking about today uh but
before we even get started you guys
already know if you have watched
two or more of our videos tell them and
you have not subscribed yeah then we
have what pearl b what do we have b okay
then so you better subscribe right now
okay bro over to you yeah guys i'm so
tired of y'all watching these streams
and not subscribings i see the analytics
i see the analytics i i see you guys it
takes two seconds hit that subscribe
button
but if you're not going to subscribe to
this channel you should subscribe to our
clips channel guys we're almost to 10k
subs on the clips channel you are
amazing you're awesome you literally got
that to 10k subs in what a week i think
we started it on the first yeah yeah
like crazy crazy on top of that guys we
have three um
members only tiers now we have the five
dollar tier the 10 tier oh the three the
100 tier in the 500 tier and the fourth
tier that means you get a one-on-one
call with me once a month you also can
connect with us on social media on the
third tier
um we're also doing a members only live
stream so if you want to see what we do
after the show you can see what we talk
about we're going to order pizza on
wednesday and answer some questions but
on a members only live stream also
follow my instagram just.pearlythings
also we are getting close to 250
subscribers and i hate myself
i hate myself for promising this but i
did promise a 24-hour live stream
at 250k i thought that wouldn't happen
for months but i guess this is a good
problem to have we're projecting it
maybe saturday i think i think saturday
yeah i think that's when we're gonna do
the 24 hour live stream hopefully we hit
it by then so hit that subscribe button
um all of the memberships are going
towards up studio updates so we're
probably going to move either this month
or next month um we want to be able to
take some of the guests from the show
and and launch like little side channels
so we want to do like a dating show we
want to do smash or pass we want to do
we want to do wife school we want to do
like a cooking classes like bunch of
different stuff that i think would be
really cool but we need the consistent
membership so we can rely on that for
rent so it's really important that we
have that consistent
memberships and on top of that if you
want to be on the show dm eddie um the
link to his instagram is in the
description he's our recruiter so if you
want to come on the show the best way i
have a lot of guys that want to come on
the best way that you want if you want
to get on the show to come on is to tell
eddie that you have girls and actually
have them like bring girls on the show
because the girls are a lot harder to
recruit for than guys so we always have
a surplus of guys that want to come on
girls it's a little bit harder
so that's all my announcements right
but we have some guests with us today
yes
so if you guys and girls um don't want
to misgender anybody today um if you
guys and girls can go around and let us
know your age uh relationship status
and a fun fact about you
um fun fact
i'm a part-time comedian okay she's
32
and my name is
kieran yeah um my name is deborah i'm
26.
a fun fact about me
nothing
oh well
okay
my name's daniel everyone calls me
franklin i've been here before uh
26 years old i'm in a relationship
because that was what you asked
and a fun fact about myself
um
damn you know you know when you're
on the spot now hey you're on this i'm
on the spot now i tell everyone i'm 6'5
but i'm actually just under 6'5
okay
okay
hi my name is storm
i am 24 years old
i am married
and my fun fact is i lived in china and
i can speak conversational
chinese
these are cantonese
well they have mandarin and then they
also have cantonese so
many people that live in hong kong speak
cantonese okay yeah
my name's sire aka saya the god i have
i'm 34.
um i'm in a relationship and fun fact is
um i don't really know fun fact i do um
i hate raisins and i love spinach
is there like a correlation fair enough
no i just just it is what it is
it made people smile you know
all right well let's get to it
um
first question ladies and gents
how many abortions
is too many abortions
wow
anyone anyone could start why don't we
go around here you start i feel like
i'm interested
how many too many he just you have a
look on your face i'm like i just want
to see what you got to say
i suppose one is probably too many
abortions
okay
yeah i think i think having any is is
too many to be honest
i think there's a mathematical equation
[Laughter]
yeah it's a
i don't think it's weird to say these
things because it's like i don't think
there's a number i can give you but
there's a lot of things i can take into
account with these things
like if you're in a long-term
relationship with a person and for
whatever reason whatever things happen i
can give you one per long-term
relationship ah huh so if you're
if she's if she's no obviously not 20
but if you're like 40 and you've been in
two ten year long relationships and for
whatever reason you had to have an
abortion for what if you've been in 40
you should have kids with all due
respect yeah of course but i'm saying
it's circumstance that's why i'm giving
it like a mathematical equation for
relationship time kind of relationship
all that kind of stuff because you never
know what people's life stories are at
the end of the day isn't it
is it worse to abort a kid when you're
in a relationship because you know that
you know that person's stable of course
so so why do they get a pass almost but
you don't know that person is stable
sometimes
that's why that's why it has to be a
mathematical equation with a lot of a
lot of intake
there's no number i can give you i have
to give you an e equals m c squared
so i just okay so so i'm 25 how many
abortions is too many abortions for a 25
year old anyway more than one is crazy
okay
so a third a 30 year old is it two
thirty five three
forty four
thirty five and been in two six or more
year relationship i can give you two
but why have you basically stay on long
term because you never wait
i've got a question for you ask me
is your answer based on personal
anecdote and i'm not saying you
personally but someone that you have
like hold close did you have been in a
situation yeah and therefore yeah your
role is based on yes
i agree with that 100 because because
i've seen some of the other side of like
oh okay cool i had this preconceived
conception of like
abortions and then when you see someone
like literally
have no other obviously i don't want to
be like those feminists who come in oh
whoa
it's
it's not what i'm saying this is what
i'm saying it's a case by case basis
with bare equations and there's so many
things you have to take into account but
if you're just an average person who's
just living average life and you're 20
something years old you shouldn't really
have more than one unless your
situations are die over [ __ ]
really when i when i know people that
have had abortions i just think they're
stupid
why is that why is that how did you get
pregnant
a lot of factors
so it's so easy not to that's one of the
things you have very easy to know it's
very very easy it's very easy to know
we have too many options yeah yeah
you bypassed all of them yeah every
single one yeah so sometimes you meet
those people who literally are falling
because i don't want to air people's
business out but like you're in a
you're in an abusive relationship with
this guy you had to do it on the
download because he didn't know you're
pregnant because if he knows you're
pregnant
then that's a mad one on your on you
because he's already abusive again i
don't want to sound like these was she
was she hit was she hitting back no of
course not you sure very sure most of
the most the most abusive relationships
again i agree if you want to understand
that but this the again is this goes
back to us i've said it again like a
million like i'm personal but yeah it
goes back to
probably with personal anecdotes that
have stories of situations where if i
was to see that situation again i could
at least give
some sort of a
day pass
but it has to be a day pass and it can't
be a thing where this is like a regular
occurrence
okay what about you
um i think after one
it's too many
and even and even with that it's
questionable because if you're laying
down unprotected you know there's a
chance you can fall pregnant yeah
you know what i mean so even that's
questionable but then again
like you said with your whole
mathematical equation whatever i teach
maths but i don't know where you got
your mathematical equation from i've got
two a's in gcse
yeah
don't worry about that yeah but
but yeah um
yeah i think after
one
let's say you have this out of a
of this world excuse and you got
pregnant you didn't know you got
pregnant you're not ready okay that's
fine now that's one
second time you're pushing it um
there's abstinence ever
sorry yeah absolutely yes i'm sorry just
yeah yeah just two yeah i was just gonna
say does abstinence not ever fall into
this equation because for me i i waited
me and my husband we waited until
marriage i feel like
if if you don't want to have children of
course then you you need to ensure that
you're waiting to have sex until
marriage yes how long are you with him
um we got to
[Laughter]
we got married um last year so we were
together for about nine months oh wow
nine months yeah so we both waited until
marriage okay and so i think when you
look at it from that scenario you kind
of have to think okay how
how how do you how do you want to see
the outcome of your life ultimately if i
don't want to have children
and i want to wait to ensure that i'm
doing it in the safest space which is in
a family you're religious
i am religious yeah well i'm christian
so yeah yeah that's so cute you guys
waited that's so rare nowadays
especially especially like it's rare for
guys i don't know like
i think there's a lot more women that
may
attempt to do that but guys i don't know
maybe maybe maybe born again they're in
a lot of virgin girls
statistically more men are virgins than
women yeah one of three men under 30 are
either virgins or haven't had sex in the
past year yeah
yeah that was like my husband when i met
him yeah but your husband was a virgin
no no he was not he was not approaching
but that was
[Laughter]
guys speak one at a time please were you
a born-again virgin too well when i met
him yeah
okay i'll celebrate for like six months
no that's not a bullying
i don't count no no no no he's most a
long time so you were more sexually
active than he was
according to him yeah according to him i
don't know you know that's what he was
saying right he was yeah but you know i
wasn't there what do you think how many
abortions is too many abortions
i would probably say three three three
you know what certain things can happen
in it your womb is just a graveyard at
that point yeah but yeah yeah as we say
sometimes when bringing up children is
not the easiest so they might have to
make certain decisions yeah but
what type of what type of things can
happen
use a condom condom you might know where
the condom condom might break um padding
i've heard the situation of a girl not
really they might not be taking them
there's a lot of
there's a lot of things i think can
happen to people
with them why don't they just deal with
the consequence so their consequence is
raising a child
yeah i mean most people throughout all
of human history were poorer
like like we're richer today than we
ever were you mean like financially yeah
but i'm saying like yeah but like i feel
like if you make your bed you should lie
yeah
i don't know but if you have the
opportunity to imagine it
you're saying that people can't take the
pill and stuff like that or they forget
to take the pill yeah but um
if you forget to take the pill you've
now got a decision to make right and
that decision is you're going to have to
kill kill your child yeah or raise a
child for the rest of your life and if
you know those are the options wouldn't
you remember to take the pill or take
the warning
yeah because those two consequences are
too dire for me not to take
my medication or whatever the appeal or
whatever it is i just i don't know i
don't get it i think we also can't
separate
like when you have sex you are there is
the potential of having a child but also
if you look at planning like um you can
literally you can plan when to get
pregnant they have calendars to ensure
that you're able to
plan when you're going to get pregnant
in fact when you look at it it's
actually a really small window
so i think ultimately we have to
be responsible for the decisions that we
make and if we are going to you know lie
with somebody of course that comes with
multiple other consequences as well then
we have to make sure that we're going to
we're going to take those consequences
on as well if we end up having a child i
think the
argument that that it just happened is a
really kind of when someone says that i
always look like
it's really disingenuous to say it just
happened because we're all fully
functioning
sentient beings do you know what i mean
we know what's happening do you know
what i mean we know that from
since we were in school
if you lay down
it creates babies do you know what i
mean that's what happens you can't
there's there's so many different ways
that you can that you can
not have as you said there's so many
different ways that you can just not
it's really easy not to get pregnant
that's true you know i mean in 2022 it's
very easy
so it's it does nothing just happens so
i have a question for the room how many
people um raise your hand if you know
someone personally that's had an
abortion
okay so i've just anecdotally
was that were were they being careful
or were they being reckless
reckless reckless careful
reckless reckless for one of them
careful from one of them
i suppose it would be it would be
reckless but i think it was also because
they were young and didn't have
the understanding
because every every person i know that's
had an abortion they weren't using
anything like not not a single form of
birth control they're just shooting up
that's crazy
yeah and that's what that's why most of
most abortions happen just based off of
you know decisions that you could have
made
just if you're a little bit smarter
you know people um listen everybody
likes sex men and women they like sex
but
there's just for me there's just a way
in which to have it so you know that you
don't get the worst outcome of having
sex i think as adults even growing up in
the uk we have sex education in schools
we know what happens do you know what i
mean and it's just like i think the
excuses
become too much after a while i think
that but i think some people also have
the mindset that it will never happen to
them
yeah
that too but how how would you like oh i
won't get pregnant
kind of thing so if a man ejaculates
inside a woman i won't get pregnant yeah
i don't think
i don't think
women really think like that unless
they've been told that they can't get
pregnant i think women know that there
is a chance all the time that i could be
pregnant you know that you've it's been
ingrained but also it's not just women
remember you've got people that are
having sex from young young that don't
always have the knowledge
are you stupid you're young you're not
stupid some people don't always know
this no i mean i'm sorry i'm sorry like
my sister's 13. and she knows about she
she's like they they know they know even
younger nowadays with the internet they
do but then you also have sometimes
women or not even women sometimes people
can be not peer pressured but they might
feel like they have to do that for the
guy to make them feel like okay this is
what i'm doing even though they say
so i'm curious from the men here
if you
anecdotally you could either say this
for you personally or friends of yours
you know you don't say name name if you
haven't worn a condom has it been
because of you or because of the girl
because of the girl
i i swear to god i sweat
the thing is the thing is the thing is
i'm happy i'm very happy you brought
that question up because that's a
question that doesn't really get brought
up how many times is it actually her but
oh he took the column off [ __ ]
have any of you ever because this has
happened to me i've only ever been
having sex with a condom with a girl and
she's asked you to take it off yes yeah
yeah yes yes she was trying to try yes
right i didn't by the way
i don't know but i'm just saying that
it's happened and i'm just like
you want me to do what
she was like oh my it will feel better
and i'm like like
that's not happening
that's just not happening yeah because
what would that what would have happened
after let's say she does get pregnant
and now she's saying to the world oh he
took it off without me knowing blah blah
or you you yeah then the guys who
sex when a lot of times they just want
to do it yeah yeah and a lot of times
they don't as well
what do you mean no a lot of times like
yes a woman can be pressured into having
sex like maybe trying to please her man
or whatever but they do
sorry
like
the fact of a baby like growing
obviously it's growing in our bodies
yeah do you know what i mean and we and
we can stop that from happening let's
say um you have sex raw
and um he claims he's pulled out
and that's one
because anecdotally that's happening
yeah i see i just don't buy that the
first part when you're saying like they
don't want to have sex because here's
the thing like
if a girl's not attracted to a guy she's
not letting him touch her she's just
running
yeah and i just don't see it that women
are pressured that much into having sex
i think girls are just as horny as guys
especially nowadays yeah it depends but
i do know somebody who
never enjoyed sex
until they met the person that they
married
but they'll just have it because
obviously they're in a relationship they
want to be submissive they want to do
right by their man would you say that's
the exception or the rule
um
now it depends on which side of the
world you uh which culture we're talking
about i don't know but for my culture i
don't think that's the exception mm-hmm
what's it where are you from well my
parents saw their name okay and and
actually it's there's somewhere on
google that actually garnier women are
the least sexually um liberated
and satisfied
do you guys think a woman's orgasm
matters
of course
no
it depends it depends on matters to
i think i think it's nice it's nice to
have it's nice it's a nice to experience
because it makes you as a guy it makes
you feel like yeah i did that do you
know what i mean i did that
so in in that way it matters but i think
any other way no not really like you
only need one to create life
true so i think throughout history i
don't think women were really sexually
like they didn't know anything different
like the only reason women know if
they're sexually unsatisfied is because
they've slept around
oh no if you're having sex then it hurts
you know you're on something like what
are you going to compare it to oh okay
you said if it hurts fine yeah however
however the clitoris is solely for
stimulation
so
there's no other there's no there's no
other reason for the clitoris
so
it's there for a reason so would you say
women that perhaps like they don't feel
anything like in their clitoris like
that thing is useless would you say that
whoa whoa what would you mean would you
mean useless
okay all right let me talk about
abortion anyway
i i have a kind of crazy stat
um did you know that 40 of women that
have had abortions have already had two
or more mm-hmm
that's that's in the u.s and the uk
very crazy stuff what's that free all
together two or more yeah two or more
and so and they don't track
and they don't track the sixty percent
like how would they know what sixty
percent have we're going to have them in
the future yeah so it's probably higher
yeah
i've had this conversation we've
family i've had this conversation with
friends i think that
getting
for for a woman getting pregnant is a
choice and sometimes they'll uh you know
society will have you think that it's an
accident or it can happen by accident
not in 2022. maybe
you know maybe a hundred years ago it
could you know you it might happen by
accident you know i mean you never know
but in 2022 it's a choice it's a choice
that you make as a conscious choice
so do you guys think abortion is murder
in some cases yeah
yeah oh you you're looking at i don't
know is that he's the one that's talking
about two is fine how far how far away i
said i have an equation like say like
the morning after pill
no abortion
do you think abortion is murder
yeah
oh you do okay yeah
and also may i just quickly um state
something abortion after
12 weeks especially i think is murder
100 because that baby is formed now
and in some cases you can actually tell
the gender at 12 14 weeks my son
i had a scan
he was 14 weeks and we could actually
tell he was a boy so if you're killing a
fetus that 14 you're killing a human
and but i think i think the difficult
thing here is
there was a point in time where we
didn't have scans
so we're at the point right now where a
scan can detect a heartbeat at around
six weeks and so forth
you know who's to say that you know in a
couple years time that the the scan's
not going to be even more advanced and
you're not going to be able to detect
life even even before that
um and i think even if you look at it
like the dna code is it's pretty it
happens almost immediately it does um
and so i definitely i definitely side
with it being a murderer to be honest
what do you think of people who say that
it's
not murder and it's just a
a collection of cells and it's a fetus
and it doesn't deserve to live so are
they demand slaughter then is that what
they're played in i don't know i've
heard like pro like pro choices say it's
not you know it's not a life at this
moment in time
it's a collection of cells it's a fetus
they've used everything else to kind of
like dehumanize
what is within fetus is a living thing
pay attention your biology lessons
95 of [ __ ] 95 of biologists say that life
begins at conception
so even the science they say believe the
science until it doesn't support their
argument
yeah i mean even if we wasn't going with
that right even if we was defining life
at a heartbeat
you can detect that six weeks so if
we're defining our week six even if it
wasn't at conception
then
most women find out around that time or
maybe even later so
you know we still have to to to call it
what it is which is the truth is that is
considered a murder so i have a question
would you guys support a law that banned
abortion completely just yes or no going
around
uh
no no no
uh
no
okay
no
[Music]
yes i know
you have to give one more
one maybe yeah not to choose one you
have to choose one then yeah i'll sk
i'll skip that question
it's not the other
i'm popping out
okay girl no
no
no
pregnancies as abortion okay sorry
with the exception sorry with the
exception of extreme cases right okay
then with the exception of in the in the
life of the mother
if their mother is gonna die yeah
would you guys anyone would anyone
change their answer after i said that no
this is so complicated sorry so so hold
on let me just
so
you're saying
not to to not factor in that
i'm saying if the mother's life
is in danger she can get an abortion
outside of that no yeah i think i think
that's the only reason
that's the only reason i said no
personally is because there is those
exceptions so i would say it has to be
heavily regulated i'm talking about
heavily regulated is fine because we
heavily regulate a lot of things
when it comes to the medical
um sector so heavily regulate it but i
wouldn't say get rid of it completely
because in those situations it does
you know it wouldn't it force people to
make better decisions
yeah you know what i mean like so if
there was a law it would actually force
people to make better sexual decisions
and after one especially if after you
have an abortion you know i mean
what
why are you going on having two three
four
so question how
how do you guys think that it's a life
and not support it being banned
i suppose
sorry one more thing because if you
really think it's a kid then that's a
kid
like if you if you genuinely believe
that then that's murder so how
like because to me that like it would be
a no-brainer
trying to be politically correct i mean
i would probably i would probably change
my answer to have it banned in all
circles in all sense apart from the
exceptions that you mentioned however i
think what's what is complicated about
the discussion is that abortion
it is not and
for lack of a words it's not an isolated
incident so for example um education
needs to be improved um maybe in some
place in the world access to healthcare
um in the uk we're very privileged to be
able to have access to free healthcare
that's not the case for every everywhere
else and so i think
yes i do think that it should be however
i think it it can't just be yes we ban
it and then that's the end we have to
kind of there has to be a rollout of
education and understanding and and
making health care more accessible to
certain people that can't access it as
well so do you do you genuinely believe
that the people getting abortions aren't
educated
i was just going to ask that i think
some i think some of them are 20 22. i
don't know as you mentioned
the thing is no let me let me interject
do you know how many stupid people would
own in the world today how many stupid
people they are i think but you are
clever enough to lay down with a man
yeah but i i think you would be you
would be surprised about how many
[ __ ] idiots are in this world today
but
those things are happening
know what abortion is an idiot
so i'm going to give you a stat that
might change your perspective a little
bit only eight percent of
of children
of pregnancies below the poverty line
are aborted were one out of three women
that make over 47 thousand dollars per
year affording their pregnancy i'm not
even saying poverty
so i'm saying you don't think that like
in some way education is linked to
abortion but how many people have seen
an abortion like actually seen a video
like that that completely changes it
right but i'm saying how does it change
it when if they know what it is
well i think sometimes seeing something
and seeing
the actual process i think sometimes we
can be so far removed from the reality
of what it actually is it's it's um i
suppose it's labeled as some sort of
it's healthcare it's a right it's a
privilege but when you actually look at
the the video of an abortion it is
literally the child's feet are being
ripped from its limbs
and it is being suctioned away though
they crush the skull right but
you know i don't think women care yeah i
genuinely don't think women i think they
could watch that and they don't i talk
to women all the time on this like they
don't care so then do you think do you
think it is sorry
and so my next question would be if we
banned it would you guys support
prosecuting women
it depends
yes but again once again it does depend
on on the circumstance i actually you
know
based on our discussion yeah perhaps we
should we should make a bit more means
tested
it shouldn't be that easy to get an
abortion but so let's say i got pregnant
yeah and it's it's banned it's bad yeah
like abortion's illegal yeah and i go
and i go get an abortion
should i go to jail for life
no no not life but you should be trying
maybe a year or two you might get you
should be trying no at the same rate of
like if i killed a person you should i
don't know what they sentence you to
here's 25 25 years okay 25. yeah 20
years 25 minutes 20 25 i think that's a
big one
yeah
extreme answer
maybe it was maybe manslaughter maybe
man no but again like i said you should
be tried now
jewelry
25 to life is a bit wild but you should
be you should be tried you should be
trying in that circumstance in that
situation yeah how old are you why did
you do it was it was um the sex um
consensual oh so you knew exactly what
you were yeah because think about it
think about it think about in this term
you can have two murder cases that they
both murdered someone but they both get
different time sentences
yeah so this is what i mean by like you
have to kind of have a secret of course
but i'm not saying it in our cop-out oh
look look at the expectation look at the
exceptions kind of rule it's just like a
in life right not everything is exactly
the same as the next thing and sometimes
you have to look at things in slightly a
different you have to get all the
information and make a decision after
you get off the information and some
might be more lenient than others
because of that do you think do you
think in the eyes of the law they should
take individual circumstances into
account or do you think it should just
be did you break the law
individual circumstances 100
so then 100
doesn't that now make the law subjective
half the people at the top would have
been imprisoned by now but johnson would
have been
when you hit the law and the law hits
you in a way that you didn't expect it
to hit you
then you're going to realize oh [ __ ]
wait hold on the law isn't forever the
law isn't the same everyone gets treated
differently differently
everybody gets treated differently yeah
some
what
one person might think something is was
fair and another person goes through the
same thing and sees it as unfair do you
know what i mean
everyone gets treated differently you
know what's interesting though even in
this conversation we're treating men and
women differently because it's we all
agreed that it was life and they're
committing the same crime but women get
out of it
yes that's per usual yeah and so it's
interesting because we have such a
gynocentric social order that even if we
agree it's life we can't really agree
that we send the women to jail do you
guys think that
women have become more anti-life
this generation yes
yeah one out of four women will have an
abortion in their lifetime can i ask a
question to you paul yeah go ahead do
you think in your in your world that you
created with proportions being illegal
do you think a [ __ ] and a woman who gave
an abortion should get the same lives
would you be like a gang member
do you think he should get the same the
same sentence as she gets for abortion
well did he shoot up one person hey yeah
they both killed one person
yeah if you killed a child i almost
think that's worse i'd give her i'd give
her the longer sentence honestly because
yeah but honestly because if he's he's
shooting other like gang members i'm
assuming right so in essence you could
say they both kind of they they chose
that life but the kid would they do so
it depends on the innocence of the
victim
okay so let's not go back to your point
of of it not being completely objective
but it is subjective
so so when you say
a crypt like we're just saying you say
or a gang member right
like like pearl was saying
those are those are two people who know
who chose a road yeah okay they chose a
certain road and normally you know that
road ends up a certain place yeah a
child hasn't chosen anything well i just
i think kids are treated differently in
the law like i think if you if you grape
a child versus an adult you get
different different senses yeah and so
that's that's why that's why i said it
would be longer is because that's a
child
and that's a that's a baby yeah i was
just asking that question to try and
find the the
point just trying to find a zero ground
yeah so if this is a thing yeah no i'm
just clarifying that's why it's because
it's a kid well one thing i i did want
to ask you know this whole legalization
of abortions and looking at the curve of
when it was introduced and roe versus
wade could one argue that that is a form
of population control
yeah um
no it's not even a conspiracy i mean i
mean who said conspiracy if we know how
it started yeah
yeah margaret sanger started planned
parenthood she was interested
yeah she was a eugenicist she she called
black people weeds
and so she and she's every black
neighborhood in america has an abortion
clinic
eighty percent yeah eighty percent are
within walking distance of minority
community i'm actually going to read
from the usa today yeah 23rd of july
2020
right
planned parenthood was founded by a
racist white woman margaret sanger that
was part of the history that could not
be changed they observed the writing
that the pattern of systemic racism
pay in inequity and lack of upward
mobility for black staff continues
sanger's planned parenthood mission
in in ninth in a
1939 letter to dr c j gamble sanger
urged him to get over his reluctance to
hire a full-time negro physician
as colored negroes can get closer to
their own members and more or less they
can lay their cars on the table which
means their ignorance superstitions and
doubt
like the abortion lobby today urged dr
gamble to enlist the help of spiritual
leaders to justify their deadly work
writing we do not want the word to go
out that we want to exterminate the
negro population and the minister is the
man who can straighten out the idea if
that ever occurs to any of the more
rebellious members for those identifying
historical figures with racist roots who
should be removed from public view
because of their evil histories planned
parenthood's founder margaret sanger
must join that list
yeah and you know from the usa today
so we should just be sad when we see you
know the roe versus wade and you know as
like when i watch the video it's always
a black woman yeah you're taking away my
rights have you have you seen have has
anyone been on to the instagram of
planned parenthood
if you've got an instagram of planned
parenthood yeah what i notice is that it
is marketed towards black people
if you scroll
it's just black women doing doing you
know martial
no it wasn't for with all due respect
youtube please don't delete what i'm
what i'm about to say
it's not for the white woman but
unfortunately they too they're going
down that is for the black woman because
a black woman one black woman could have
seven eight kids back then pre-seventies
do not mean it's too much
and also another another um
there was this um
this figure i think is it like black
american women they only make about five
percent or seven percent of the
population
but they make up f over 50 of abortions
as a matter of fact this is
extermination that actually segues us
into the video that we had
um
ish do you have the video that i sent
you that weekend
[Music]
that we can actually um play yeah i do
indeed
have your babies um
okay
what would you say is now the number one
cause of death in the african-american
community
heart disease
oh hiv aids
diabetes
cancer
aids
i'll say heart disease
age
from what i heard it's probably aids you
know
probably heart disease
i think heart disease
hiv
no
gang violence
what if i told you the real answer was
abortion
since 1973
legal abortion has killed more african
americans than aids cancer diabetes
heart disease and violent crime combined
every week more blacks die in american
abortion clinics than were killed in the
entire vietnam war
and the largest chain of abortion
clinics in the united states is operated
by planned parenthood
[Music]
white women have the most abortions of
any race and ethnic group but black
women
are overrepresented making up 27.6 of
all abortions while only compromising
14.9 of all women in the nation giving
them the highest abortion rate
in the united states
don't take it down yet
i want everybody
who is watching the stream
to just screen save that
yeah
yeah
let's read on but let's go on yeah
african-american women are also
overrepresented in four of the major
factors that lead to abortions
unintended pregnancies
relationships
lack of contraception use
and poverty
do you think anna doink let's read the
first slide please okay so remove
statues of margaret sanger planned
parenthood founder thais
founder title eugenics and racism
how a woman who advocated for the
selective breeding
of her fellow citizens came to be more
to lie small yeah
memorialized sorry with those who built
a country is hard to understand
would you say it's hard to understand
that don't thanks for that would you say
it's hard to understand
that the founder
of planned parenthood
was a racist and a eugenicist no
what statue did they just take down in
black lives matter and where is it
are we back ish
[Applause]
abortion abortion abortion through
abortion no but why is it specifically
like blacks so right because essentially
um
[Music]
planned parenthood or abortions were
marketed to the black community they
were marketed to black women because the
founder margaret sanger wanted to kill
black children
she was a
racist and white supremacist she wanted
to get rid of the black population so
they so her plan was
if we can get them before they even come
out of the womb
right then we can get them and so
abortions were actually marketed to the
black community specifically in america
and this is the result now black women
are getting rid of their children at
some times four times the rate of any
other person per capita yeah but i think
it just so happens that in in a lot of
ways it kind of
backfired a little bit because even the
roe v wade now i think
the the structures in
again america and places like that these
are white structures these are white
supremacy structures do you know what i
mean so
those structures know that you know that
abortions are happening more and more
with their populations
so they're trying to
you know retain
uh numbers in their own populations
that's why they would i think that's the
reason why they would um
sort of say no to abortions in terms of
a federal level because they're trying
to i think it's more
you know scared of just being
um
phased out in in in a in you know in the
white suprema white supremacy head is is
this the way of being phased out you
know i mean yeah that was an unwanted
casualty of war that was not you know
what i mean yeah yeah exactly exactly
because that man that mindset is a real
mindset is even in the uk have you heard
like any people i don't know how much
you've heard of any like bnp or ukip
guys talk about the population issue
cronkite yeah about immigration ethnic
minorities yeah there's
like there's like a ratio that they keep
bringing up that white
mothers and parents are having kids that
are slower rate than than coloreds and
blacks so they
their fear whenever you if you were able
to go ask one of them is that at some
point they will become the minority
because there'll be so many ways and if
you look at the graph that's what's
gonna happen
and you keep and like um
basically
basically tiki torches but in england
but i think it's already been predicted
though especially yeah
and that's the fact that the american
population by a certain point
is going to white the white population
yeah 50 years
60 or something it's going to be the
minority and for a lot of a lot of white
people that's scary yeah
that's scary to know okay you know they
got to retain some numbers
i get it i understand it in that i don't
know a lot of white people that care and
a lot a lot of white people that don't
care at all they're like i don't know
white people
let's all mix up you know what i mean
one at a time sorry one at a time sorry
keep going i'm gone
yeah sorry um yeah pearl you're saying
that you um you don't know
of many people caring but obviously for
some of the
white conservatives and liberals
it is something you know i mean
especially history especially based on
history because now if these don't
become the majority what does that make
of us well go ahead and say that in your
mind sorry like if if these people
that we called negros and whatnot
like in some cases and history of
slavery and whatnot if they become the
majority now what happens to us and it's
okay everyone's fighting for their
survival that's no problem i just
genuinely don't know anyone in 2022 that
cares like no that's not this is our no
obviously it's our parents yeah and our
grandparents
you say that
you're around you say that but the other
day in america when the guy shot up all
those black people in buffalo oh yeah um
his manifesto did state that he was
actually you know
upset about the population of certain
types of people so that yeah there
definitely are people around i think i
think white liberals are the most racist
actually
they're the ones supporting these
policies yeah yeah white they're
probably followed by black league yeah i
think it was
followed by black malcolm x
they also support like things like
quotas yeah yeah which i i think is
offensive
yeah
whenever i hear the phrase black people
can't be racist it irks me so much black
people can't be racist it really burns
my whole heart because it's like
then define what racism is because when
when that white person called you a
derogatory phrase you've claimed racism
you didn't claim prejudice you know i
think i think i think there's a
difference between racism and race
prejudice
what do you mean
i think i think race predict i think
everyone can be race prejudice
everyone black white
whoever thank you i think systematic
racism is different
race prejudice yeah of course and i
think that's that's right and i think
that's what people get confused i think
they get systematic or systematic
oppression they get confused with race
prejudice anyone can be race prejudiced
a chinese man can wake up tomorrow and
say i don't like white people do you
know what i mean
anyone can do that you know i mean i
just think system systems
are different
and that is the real racism because as
black people let's be honest
as black people we don't have the
institution
the wealth the money or the power in the
west in the west
even no even even in our continent
with all due respect ghanaian owned by
the ghanaians the ghanian airport is
owned by a turkish billionaire
you know what i mean so we do not have
the power to be racist you may say make
a little joke about oh
when you see when you said that yeah
you're saying you don't have the power
to enforce
no to force racism
what do you mean by systematic racism
like i'm just curious like what
institutions so okay so institutions
like the police
the police force people say are
institutionally racist over here in i
think was 2007 they we had a
a guy called burner bernard hogan how he
was like the head of the metropolitan
police
and he was the head of the it's like
being the head of the police in america
right and he said oh you know well if
people say you know our institution our
institution is institutionally racist uh
that's something we're gonna have to
take on the chin right that's what he
said as as the head
of the police so he knew
to some degree that his institution was
racist so institution so institutional
racism i believe actually exists
but
individual like race prejudice also
exists and i think sometimes people get
the two misconstrued and you can go as
far as saying but one is more real than
the others
have been historically racist like
redlining like redlining in america like
that was an institutionally racist thing
do you know what i mean like there is
institutional racism and i think people
get say oh that's racist it's like well
i i say the way to attack
attack racism would be institutionally
what are the institutions that enforce
like schools or i don't know education
yes where they're teaching i don't know
a racist
i don't know doctrine in school or
something something like that i think
for those of us that don't know what
redlining is could you just explain that
okay so redlining was where um
if you wanted to buy a house right in
america um certain banks would not give
loans to black people right they would
only give them to white people so that
as the banking as an institution became
a racist institution because it was not
giving loans
to black businesses and two black people
for them to become wealthy yeah to go to
go into a business and when did that
like stop it
that's that's one of the things where
even even i get looked at a bit wildly
yeah like institutional racism does
exist in certain areas but i think
certain things are just
they need to find a new because
redlining doesn't happen anymore it
doesn't exist it's on paper yeah on
paper that's what i'm saying so on paper
so
institutionally even that it has we have
to find a new like covert institution no
because i have a class
in america so south africa was an
institutionally racist state yeah do you
know what i mean so institutional racism
exists but i think people need to
differentiate between what is
institutional racism and what is
individual race prejudice so i'm just
curious with the redlining thing like
what what happened so they they found
that like they were lending at different
rates so basically to go into more a
little bit more information so so to put
it in the context of this room what they
would do is they would say i'm gonna the
good banks would say i'm gonna give a
loan but
only to people who live draw a line
right through us yes over on that side
right knowing full well that they put
all the black people post slavery in a
certain area and then cutting off the
line of where they would give loans to
if you lived right if you lived in the
hood you couldn't get along because you
lived in the hood right but the thing is
it was like a chicken meat egg situation
because it's like you put them there
forcefully post whatever and then after
you put them there with no actual other
way to go
they can get loans to go live in the
middle class areas of the higher class
areas but i thought this was in like the
60s yeah so that was like a long time
after slavery so they could have moved
no i mean yeah but like but you have to
also no i mean like because there is
mass migration i don't know like i
there's mass migrations in the us from
the south to the north yes and so you
can't say no because a lot of a lot of
them did but it became it was more of a
thing where it was um it was uh if i was
to think
politically it was a attack the mindset
type of thing where if you know how some
people like once they're in the hood
that's just their mindset right and with
all some people eat sleep breathe the
hood it doesn't matter and they want to
live there for the rest of their they've
grown comfortable that's where they feel
safe now because because in my head like
why would you lend to people that live
in the hood
more yeah like i'm not i know
because usually like i'd imagine like in
poor communities you're not as good at
paying back money yeah
but imagine imagine imagine more of
creating a hood to then say why would i
give people in the hood money you know
you know tulsa you know the um
neighborhood coast of oklahoma tulsa
yes yes black wall street i'm sure pearl
you've heard about it obviously
no i don't know what that is okay so
black black wall street was a place in
america after slavery where black
millionaires existed there were loads of
black millionaires there were you know
business owners it was a they had their
own like black economy where was that at
it was in tulsa oklahoma oklahoma okay
okay yeah so in tulsa oklahoma there was
this huge town like black people own
their own planes they had their own
businesses they were like
multi-millionaires they knew the stock
market all this kind of stuff and then
what happened was
the kkk and like other groups literally
burnt the town to the ground bombed it
from the the the the army bombed it from
the sky just totally got rid of that
town like killed everybody in the town
and i don't even see mississippi burning
that film called mittisibi burning
um
similar to that so
is this something to do with redlining
no i don't know okay
because the red lining came shortly
after that if you actually look at the
it did it came after that after they've
burned down this black um economy
redlining came in where was redlining at
like what cities worldwide oh it's all
over america
it was it was like a 50-state thing
where we have gone off topic but we have
no i i just genuinely i don't know a lot
about it
yeah essentially it was it was it was a
thing where state by state it was it was
statewide so it was a thing where at the
time it just seemed
like oh it was just the right thing to
do but when we when we look at it like
that's [ __ ] up and the the reason like
a lot of the hoods that exist today
exist today where they are is because
those are the predators because of the
red line put all those poor people who
had no money and no fun to get out of
there so their families have lived there
for generations after generations but
that was like my dad was from the hood
and he just like left yeah so i'm like
what's stopping you from leaving the big
thing the big things
if you make like good choices and work
hard you can move out and it's not
no and that's what my dad was one of 13
kids he like grew up on the south side
of chicago in like a really bad area
you can in 2022 you can i don't disagree
with you yeah
so i just i just i don't know i'm just
kidding it's easier said than done but
you can do it if you've got that mindset
if you've got that mindset you can do it
but you also have to know
when you're when you were talking you
were like it just sounded like you're
saying they're like put there and i'm
like but anyone can move yeah and even
and even like throughout history there's
always been like mass migrations of like
groups of people like for example like
if you go into certain communities in
new york like maybe at one point they
were very jewish dominated or irish
dominated and you look over the course
of history they're not anymore because
people move and like different yeah so
like now if there's nothing stopping you
from moving like i don't yeah you don't
see the reason why but there but like
for everything
it's a generational mindset thing which
is why now now we live in a time where
more and more we since about like what i
think it's like individual choices yeah
yeah yeah yeah but which is which is why
we're seeing a lot of people like
coming out of the hood and there's all
these movies coming out blah blah blah
but like back in like
when redlining was a real thing there
was literally you can't you can't move
anywhere because you don't have the
money for transport oh no i just went
today because i thought we were talking
about yeah that's what i i don't i don't
know i'm not pretending to know about it
i'm just trying
i'm just trying to understand it yeah
in terms of like
like i don't
when you were talking when you talk
about um institutional racism and i said
you have to also call it like one
section cover and one section over
redlining doesn't exist on paper no it
exists in theory so it's a battle of the
mind to get yourself out of there
because like paul said we live in a time
where you can do whatever you want so it
doesn't exist
now exist
have you seen that have you seen that um
that thing where where you've got like
the little spider yeah and then they
draw the line around the spider and it
won't go in it won't go out so can i
just i'm just gonna why is my comments
all saying it says the red lining was
based they don't give loans to poor
people
yeah that's what that was that's right
well it depends on the subset because
like if you look in the u.s like
different sub subsets of um
of like there's a slave i think it was
the caribbean they outperformed white
people in a lot of cases so like there's
certain subsets of black people that
outperform white people like nigerians
even indian americans they outperform
everybody so when you say like oh like
who's who's poor it could be like irish
irish had a lower gdp per capita
i actually think poor yeah being poor is
a mindset yeah
your surroundings i think that a lot of
a lot of people now have been so used to
being poor that they get
now growing up black right and growing
up poor because i grew up poor
you get told certain things when you're
black and poor
right you get fed a certain narrative
when you're black and poor
and a lot of the time you believe it and
so your mind stays being black and poor
oh my god i can't do much i'm not gonna
be able to do anything this is gonna be
um who i am for the rest of my life and
if you stay in that mindset you actually
will be 100
but to answer your question earlier with
the with the chat saying you you can't
make people you have to also take into
account the fact that businesses would
also use redlining for hiring
so you can't even go to the job and say
i want a job here because i'll ask where
you live
and then because if you're if your house
is past the red line and yeah we'll give
you today we'll give it a job so you can
get the job to move out you can get the
place that you wanted to work in order
to even save the money to move out
because redlining was a thing that was
entrenched in all levels of government
right at the time right from from all
the way down to the shopkeeper on a
day-to-day basis to the senator at the
top
so the reason i'm just asking because i
think she said like institutional racism
right and so i was just curious because
um i'm irish and so a lot like they had
a lot of similar like they would say
like irish need not apply when they
first came and they would live in a lot
of the same community no blacks no irish
no dogs yeah and so and so so i was just
curious what i don't really under i
don't understand or that like
because irish irish had it were
indentured servants and they actually
had lower life expectancies than slaves
because they were cheaper so they would
have to do a lot of the harder jobs and
they would like die quicker in the uk
it's also because of the
they're between northern ireland and
republic of ireland and the rest of
england so that is one of the reasons so
you know when
the the england was invading
and you know colonizing then they had
like uh i think it's republic northern
or republic one of the two um yeah there
was a whole schism there so they were
like all right no irish so it was part
of that too so yeah it has like a
language because i was thinking that the
no irish part was from the history no
yeah that's what i was thinking but the
no blacks it's like these people are
different they're dirty do you know what
i mean so it's kind of different
but i was just wondering because you
said institutional racism and so i was
wondering like if it would be the same
for people that were irish and lived in
those communities i don't know probably
it wasn't there wasn't an irish
equivalent of reading yeah okay
i know of there might be
from my history of research there wasn't
an irish equivalent of redlining the one
thing i will add with that is when it
came to redlining when blacks did try to
move into the neighborhoods what they
would do is they'd try and get a lawyer
that was white to sign off yes
yeah and then when they moved over
and they saw like for the final day's
worth of paperwork
the real estate agent or whoever was
selling the place would beg them not to
move and give them every excuse in the
book to ensure that they didn't move on
the basis that if that black person had
moved into the neighborhood the price
the prices of the houses would go down
in that area
so it was all like a business plot to
say like if we allow a black person in
the neighborhood
um
it was from top down it was it was one
of those things where in in every area
and sector it affected so it's one of
those things where obviously one hundred
percent the effects of it still live on
today well no it's it's interesting
sorry go ahead finish this yeah
but
to the point that we were making before
i i kind of
i don't believe in the victim mindset in
a general sense so i i always get i
always get called uh insensitive and
don't care about people's feelings when
i say that you're only a victim because
you made yourself a victim well because
i want to
the reason the reason i'm asking is
because
i learned a lot i don't know if you've
ever heard of um thomas sowell
he talks about on his book like the most
discriminated group is like people that
come from um it's like called redneck
culture
and basically like white and black
people that both derived from that
culture had similar economic outcomes
and so like when you see race relations
get really bad and the reason um like
irish get grouped like in with like the
same sort of things with like no no
blacks no irish it's because they're
both from that culture and so when you
saw mass migrations to the north
that's when you would see like things
like and i think i remember in his book
them talking about redlining because
before like in the 20s 30s 40s the the
black people that were in the north
actually
were like
coexisting fine it wasn't until the mass
migration came and then even the people
that were like from the north would
discriminate against the people from the
south they were like the same skin color
because it was about the culture that
was coming in
[Music]
yeah and so and so it's interesting
because you'll you'll see um
i'm like my heart's pounding i don't say
the wrong thing
and the reason like there was such a
disparity was because nine out of every
10 black people in the us derived from
that culture where only one out of every
three white people did and the culture
was actually from england and it's like
a lot of um like when you hear black
pride it used to be called cracker pride
before that prize yeah when they say in
the us that's a common phrase they say
black pride yeah and when you say it
like
and i don't even like to like
say like when you hear certain like
dialects like they came
like from england yeah so the thing is
right this conversation on conversations
like this even though we've gone like
way off topic right like i think it's
great because i think
i think in america this couldn't happen
nowhere
in this conversation yeah i think yeah
it would be so emotional like yeah
shouting at each other like going crazy
like what the [ __ ] you mean
yeah and i just think i don't know i
think we have a different temperament
over here do you know when it comes to
you know who gets it the worst and this
might be a i don't know if anyone
notices it but
ginger people get it again
the stuff that people say yeah like
openly
just to this ginger people
sometimes i'm like whoa
what was that i think it's ginger guys
to be honest yeah it's definitely
gingerbread yeah no no you're redheaded
women are actually like desired and
stuff gingerman no one knows ginger men
i don't think that i don't think people
mean that like really too much better
but oh man on a daily basis
yeah but did you see that [ __ ] have you
seen the south park episode about they
say they say jokingly but i've seen it
this is why it's called the grey area
because we are going into the gray areas
sorry were you going to read the super
chat as well oh should i i probably
should yeah like yeah well we're talking
about oh yeah abortions yeah
we're going to get back
well i feel like when those mass
migrations happened like that's when you
see a lot of the like racist policies
come in yeah and that's when you see a
lot of like the population control
efforts because it wasn't even margaret
singer like it wasn't necessarily she
also believed in like aborting people
with low iqs and like poor people
basically
even even though she like absolutely was
racist like she also was a dumbest
i don't know what like
i curious
and it's like i just think
like that's when all the creatures all
the form of ins is just talking about
institutional racism that's where that
margaret sanger that's her foundation
it's that institutional race of white
supremacy which just put her in that
position i don't think we live in a
world of covert institutional racism
because all the institutional racist
things that were put in place no longer
on paper are there yeah and they're
gonna remove it off paper because they
don't want somebody
going in their papers i'm fine which is
which is why i'm saying
the police is still institutionalized so
who today who is they they is there like
for example there isn't nobody just no
it's kind of like a lot of no it's just
like a lot of times like when we say you
know these ins they're like there's
these like we're saying things about
institutions and people but we don't
name them
right and so it's kind of like it's kind
of like when um
there was the whole um interview with
oprah and meghan markle
but she was saying that you know the
institution basically you know they
basically dishonored me but what she
really was trying to say is that a bunch
of white people at the top basically
didn't give me what i wanted or do you
know what i mean meghan markle's crazy
you know she's like that's what i'm
saying you guys
you guys
what did you think you were doing but
she loves him though she already came to
me i would have said she loves it i mean
can we not sit here and say that we saw
the news articles that came out weekly
about her just everything
one at a time people sorry the amount of
news articles that came out about dumb
[ __ ] like her holding her bump in a way
that was worse megan i enjoy being a
duchess that's the same thing as having
unprotected sex and complaining yeah
yeah
freaking who you're a royal and the
tabloids complain about you
boo hoo married cry me a freaking river
okay
i have to cry
i have to cry she'll be an equivalent
don't you know your husband's history
before marrying him i believe
i'm just saying megan merkel as a person
i'm just not a fan anyway
i don't know
twice
how did the royal family gain their
wealth thank you through racism through
racism if you choose to go and marry
into a
historically racist family
that's your business
she might not have known that why excuse
me
okay i'm sorry i'm sorry you're marrying
in the into the royal family and you're
not going to google yeah
that is that is a 30-something that is
that is a 30-something year-old woman
you you chose that family you made your
bed lioness
we gotta look it like this come on all
of us right now can google the royal
family but until we actually go into
that situation you're not gonna know
what's gonna happen no no you're going
well equipped that's why you google this
my whole point is if you get
disrespected leave and that's what she
did no but what's your fault
she still wants to be touched
then harry she still wants to get out of
here they both do not not he should
leave her
not leave her
kids there's kids
they're happy yeah
a female over a female this is
it's not just megan that's taunting him
from from the family though i think
secretly
he's had some disagreements with the
family that's probably yeah his mom
different generation he's a mom
they killed him
that's probably true that's that's what
but then
okay okay so it magically happened when
they got married come on no but hang on
none of that no but it was time to calm
harry isn't it it's time to come prince
william's baby
you oh
berkshire i'm a black man who grew up in
the hood i purchased a house in a good
neighborhood and now i'm getting ready
to sell and buy a new better house and
acquiring rental property redlining
ended decades ago semaine tagan do you
guys think there's a correlation between
the new swirl and divest movement and
reducing the black population
still low key 21. the concept of black
people and white people only exist
because the irish and black people were
united under oppression look up the
francis rebellion y'all rolled into the
deep waters with this topic matt butcher
people get discriminated against in
dozens of different ways it's far from
just race zentians so if redlining was
used to disregard people past a certain
line to exclude a demographic why aren't
women and the left equally as enraged
and passionate as this group when it
comes to affirmative actions or family
courts
okay guys guys guys i need you to stop
interrupting me when i'm reading the
shots okay um alistar horton take the
deepest breath you can pearl um quad god
redlining is another myth of economic
inequality read books by award-winning
award-winning black economist thomas
sowell that's what i was saying i felt
like he talked about this in his book
but i didn't want
it to misquote him and i swore he was
saying it was about income it wasn't
about race but i don't i don't know i
don't want to like be misquoted miloshin
wil wilson to me it's funny how young
conservatives can't see racism today but
black people in america are still
fighting for the right to vote in 2022.
um okay monkey you sup i hate when my
fellow black brothers and sisters always
use every excuse in the world jesus
christ stop crying and boss up we're in
2022 we have more choices than ever
before
ismail rivera thomas sowell has a
segment on this different communities
congregated in different areas in the
city to streamline the ad process and
reduce default risk banks would redline
the poorest districts
worst dragon racism exists don't lie to
yourself steph stephen pierre jerome
redlining is when banks would stop stop
and restrict certain minority groups
from buying into white certain white
neighborhoods and only allow them to buy
into a certain specific area peter quad
it is still a choice when you have no
options to choose from chase colney dr
claude anderson explains a lot about
redlining eric
mendoza thank you for the super chat
dash token redlining realtors were
instructed
to only show lower income areas to black
buyers and would not show black the show
blacks the white neighborhoods this
stagnated wealth creation for blacks and
generations
alistair horton pearl um check your w-a
after would ya um what's w-a
what's up on my what's up
y'all that is not me i am not giving out
my number in the comments it's a scammer
stop responding
like
like don't stop it um oh there's no i'm
not publicly i'm just gonna say this now
i am not publicly giving out my number
that is not no that is not me okay lp
berkshire um also in most u.s
institutional racism basically means
that there are rules or laws
specifically against a specific group of
people in the u.s and there are no such
laws also in the u.s the most police
departments and major major cities are
heavily diverse where the minorities
make up most of the police most are from
the community samuel hannah you are
murdering the redlining explanation
please stop don blackswell no redlining
was about wealth the higher priced
properties were mostly in white
neighborhoods a shame white americans
don't know this admin dania population
control specific groups or not has been
practiced by the leadership of nations
throughout time egypt to the jews china
under gender control it serves one group
at the expense of another silly sausage
if government changed the rules and said
by law you have you have to have a
forced abortion every woman would fight
the government to keep the children
problem solved the bikini bottom bandit
pearl i love your show i'm happy i'm
watching your live for the first time
hold these women accountable and don't
let them make excuses the same goes for
the men
elitegamer876 thank you for the super
chat matt butcher in arizona a pregnant
lady can drive in the carpool pool lane
they see it as two people murder a
pregnant lady that's two charges young
kay the baby won't can't contribute to
society for 18 years soul x for
something if i take myself out of the
victim mentality then my mind goes i
from i can't raise them to i'm sure i
will figure out the best way i can for
their sake edgar reyes in el salvador
it's super illegal camp columbia just
recently legalized abortion leon vrp the
system is designed to destroy women in
an inverted world being a misogynist
means you wanna you want the best for
women fresh and fit andrew tate and
other red pill channels are standing up
for you ladies let me refresh it and
just make sure also guys um all super
chats are going towards studio updates
you know we already know we got a camera
show them your face show them your face
and that was all thank you to all the
super chats we've gotten the last couple
of months we want to get one more camera
so we can get this like wide angle of
sorrow look at look
show them what we got now
yeah yeah
look at how how how nice would it be if
we could if we could just do it a little
bit more forward center yeah so that's
what we're saving for now
um lp berkshire
when you use terms like like not on
paper you're basically basically ghost
hunting you have to have actual facts
and situations where you can back up
your arguments stephen pierre's jerome
in today's uh
stephen pierdrum in today's times
realtors would promote certain locations
to certain demographics they would say
to black person to buy a rather than b
then go to a white person and say buy b
rather than a silly sausage two million
irish arrived after the famine doubled
the population of new york and boston no
jobs or housing we resorted to crime
hence the irish mafia british forgot
forget famine have the irish population
from eight million to four four million
melish wilson who is they m mcco
mcconnell west west juarez
west virgo oh
west wargo i've never heard of that bank
government ron desantis et cetera if you
need more names let me know lp oh okay
that's it
okay
okay back to abortion yeah do we want to
watch the the clip that i yes yeah so
get yogurt why don't you pull up can i
just ask ask a question yeah you see on
that there was a super chat that said um
the um if if
about the baby in the in the stomach and
they're charged twice twice
so how how early is that in terms of
what what age
no right from when they're pregnant
because recently uh right from yeah
that's interesting because right because
actually recently i think it was in 2018
there was actually a lady who got
murdered in um and a black lady and she
was pregnant
and they said now they're charging the
guy for double homicide because the baby
died now the baby was eight months
but
it would have been the same if so if it
was one month it would just she would
have still been done for a double double
homicide
so that's interesting because because by
by law they're seeing that as a as a
person yeah yeah in this conversation
that we're having do you know they're
seeing that i suppose
and if we kept it consistent then like
then like then they would go to jail
yeah
but it's not gonna double yeah hundreds
is this weird it's weird that that we
got the the video huh ish we got it play
it until make it full screen and just
play it until the
girls go off
four weeks
and the earliest child to survive a
pregnancy is 21 weeks so you're aborting
children that hypothetically could
survive on their own outside the world i
think that child that was going to be
born like the life that is going to live
do you think it's going to live a good
life and then isn't that isn't that
actually being cruel to this child that
would be born my question is do you
believe that poor children are less
valuable they're not less valuable
they're just not going to have a good
value of life so why should that why
should they why should i put a child on
this earth that's going to not not have
a good quality
when i could give it a good quality of
life when i'm prepared in the future
quality of life so one i have two things
one the majority of abortions are with
women that make over forty seven
thousand dollars per year so it's not an
income thing only only eight percent of
women anything do they i don't i don't
when you're firing back at these facts i
don't they don't mean anything you're
not a person like you do you and 47
grand a year like do you earn that
would you have a baby right now could
you could you do that because to me i
don't think you should be having sex if
you can't afford a child and if you are
if you are then why why can't you get an
iud
so or or or
why can't you get an iud birth control
birth birth control in the uk is free
sometimes doesn't always work does it
but this is a common argument i hear
which is we talk about exceptions rather
than the rule if you get you call it the
coil here i i think can i can i find it
can i can i can i can i can i finish my
sentence so so the coil here is 99
effective you're actually really good at
debating yeah so i'll say that because
i'm so good at debating
i'm not trying to clickbait you i'm not
i don't edit it out i know you guys are
just walking into this i don't expect
you to have the all facts i just i just
like to understand like why you believe
but do not understand our point like the
people that are against it do you not
understand their point of view i think
their point of view is often it's my
body my choice right but i'm saying when
you take that to the extreme it doesn't
make sense have you had sex bo
i i'm not a virgin so you've had sex
what if you had a baby
but but i was i was
no but here so so so so here's the thing
here's the thing one if i got pregnant i
would keep it because to me like i i
don't believe in abortion and i have um
i have i have a brother right and my mom
got pregnant when she was a teenager and
she gave him up for adoption and so to
me it's like
do you think that's like that's a life
adoption usually kids that are in
adoptive care it's not a good life in
that sense no he had a great life he's
married
when you say things like that it's it's
the same argument people use for
eugenics do you know what eugenic says
so eugenics is basically when you're
when you're
getting a more pure population
and so a lot of times people bring
things like low iq people need to be
exterminated like poor people need to be
exterminated and when you're using the
argument of if they have a bad life
that's how eugenicists use to make their
point because you're basically you're
implying that like poor people have less
of a right to life than rich people no
we're not we're not implying that i
think to do with it
if that baby is born when it could have
been aborted that could lead into a
worser life when it could have when that
could have been prevented
right so you don't think that's saying
that poor people should have a less of a
right to life than rich people it's not
about poor or rich like it's about
quality of life that has nothing to do
you could be poor and still have a good
quality of life like that has nothing to
do with it but like the baby like it's
quality of life like you don't know if
it's going to be rich you don't know if
it's getting poor you don't know where
it's going to end up and you can't just
you can't you can't just give birth
because what if it's not a good life
like some people can't even look after
themselves yet and you're putting a baby
with them okay this is the one thing
that people don't understand about
street interviews i am always excited to
talk to you guys if you see me on the
street whatever i am so down to talk but
if i'm doing an interview it hurts the
quality of the interview when you guys
interrupt me
when
i am talking to the first person so if
you want to come up that's fine but you
have to like wait your turn
respectfully love you guys
[Music]
but again so so
so so hey hey we're doing an interview
i'd love to interview you guys next i'd
love to out here
but so again only eight percent of women
below the poverty line so the majority
do you not think facts matter well not
in when this is
that that's becoming illegal now think
of all the things that are going to
happen in america
it's just going to it's going to be
terrible why is that your your thought
that everything like what's going to
happen
it was unlegalized in the first place
like because it wasn't happening it
wasn't unlegalized you might not know
how the us government works but it's not
illegal in the u.s it's not illegal
so so the way it works in the u.s is it
state by state so you elect officials to
represent you in each state and that way
if if you're a pro-life person you can
move to a state that's pro-life if
you're pro-choice you can move to a
state that's pro-choice why should you
have to move to a state why can't you
just well that's how the u.s government
works is you you have different laws in
every state
right so again less than one percent of
abortion so but this is but so this is
this is my channel we talk about we
don't talk about exceptions we're
talking about the rule so you don't talk
about acceptance we're talking because
this is what people often will try to
make an argument using the exception
when we're talking about the rule i'm
i'm asking you to like respectfully
we're not we're not talking about that
exception
okay but that you don't actually
no be because
because 99 of abortions are due are not
in the case of grapes so we're talking
about the 99 percent
i have nothing to offer i have nothing
for the 99 that's the argument i'm
making for the 99 of abortions that are
not great it is a cop out because they
made poor decisions
what you think about with
you don't you think that grapes so grape
youtube what do you think then i'm
asking what is your opinion on grape and
that because i think you're again you're
trying to make an argument i think
you're trying to make an argument for
like the exception rather than the rule
and so this because because because it's
less than one percent of the case but
this is what because i'm not talking
about that i could see a potential
policy for exceptions but i'm talking
about the rule and the i would say okay
little things you might
even exist
they don't what what do they not exist
like they it is it's a con it's a human
concept construct that you're the rule
and the exception it's still part of it
do you not see what i'm saying
but i but this is this is what i'm
talking about 90 the nine this is the
argument i'm making i i know but this is
this is you can do that on your channel
on my channel we're talking about the 99
of abortion that that
okay we're back
yes
um
yep all right okay so what was you
guys's ladies and gentlemen i think i
think i think those two girls jaren
they they it was it was they had a very
reactive
mindset when it came to like abortion
like it's almost like everything starts
from
oh my god i'm pregnant
that's where that is literally all right
what am i gonna do like no there was no
thought put into anything before that
it's just that was the point where they
thought oh my god what we're going to do
is i just think it's is uh
is dangerous and it's funny i i think
it's funny how um
people that are
believing abortion
the ones that are going to have abortion
to people that don't have believe in
abortion chances are they're going to be
a bit more careful about what they're
doing if you don't actually believe in
abortion you're actually going to be
more careful about what you're doing
you're not going to get pregnant
do you know what i mean it's just the
carelessness that when you when you get
it's cute it's human nature when you
give someone a choice like that much
choice they're gonna just take it and
use it or when you give somebody an out
yeah yeah yeah they are not even to
think they're going to be like oh well
if it happens i'll do that i'll do that
yeah yeah if it happens i'll do that but
this is what goes back to why i said i
give an equation
considering a whole bunch of things
right the reason i said this is because
a lot of situations i'm just going to
give her a write-off obviously
but
you have to give the people who want
exceptions to be taken into account the
fact that you at least take into account
it doesn't mean i have to well in the
old days in the old days there would be
like shotgun weddings people people get
married younger with less and the kids
would turn out fine they would just
marry the dude that got him pregnant
yeah and that's not like the girls act
like that's the end of the world but
there's also a part where uh that people
forget that houses then cost like 50p
there's but there's if there's a will
there's a way yeah like like i mean you
can make money online now sure anyone
everyone has it's like the great
equalizer everyone has everything i've
learned about this [ __ ] i did online
yeah and so
everyone has access to a library but if
you like i said if you have a safety net
right like this is a thing
for human human beings are very they're
very interesting creatures because you
know psychology is it's a very
interesting thing if if you tell human
beings
you can do this or you can't do this and
these are the consequences for it human
beings are way up in their own head
they'll say okay cool i can't do that or
i can do that but they'll say if i do do
that
what happens
right now if the what happens is you die
they're not gonna do it yeah right if
there's a really like bad consequence
they're not gonna do it but if they know
that there's an out if they know there's
a safety net they'll be like they won't
take it as seriously yeah and i think
one of the one what's happening right
now today is people are literally using
abortion as contraception yes all right
they're using abortions contraception
sorry sorry go on
you know um one of the girls in there
she says she she says something and it
really struck on over me it's like oh if
i have a baby i don't want i got to do
what i need what do i need to do what do
you mean yeah but what's wrong with that
pardon what's wrong with that what's
wrong with who sorry everyone's got
their own life to live
my dear if you're no with all due
respect firstly babies though yes
with all your respect you know you're
not ready let's judge in by she's 1920
she's a student
condoms are actually free yeah but we
don't know how people become pregnant
though you can't decide you get pregnant
from having a protective sex exercise
protection sex listen
remember remember we know this
one at a time guys one at a time we're
different from america we have free
health care exactly we we can get any um
contraception for free yeah yeah so
really and truly in america you might
have an argument because you're poor or
you can't afford we don't have an excuse
here
we can get help we can get anything most
of us when you look at those grounds
most people that are having sex know
that you could possibly have a kid so
you made your bed lie in it yeah when
you look at the grounds of abortion as
well like when you actually look on like
the england and what like guava.uk when
you look at england and wales the main
abortions come from ground c
ground z 98 abortions is before 24 weeks
but then also the issue of that is that
they say that it's because of either
mental health or a physical injury but
then when you look at the notes below
that it says that 99.9 of those are
based on mental health but then the
concern with that is well i studied
psychology at university so when i think
about that if the issue is it's it's a
mental health
issue
i cannot begin to imagine
how much
the implications of that after you've
had an abortion like even when you look
at studies you see that people are
depressed you see that they even have
nightmares they have fear of being
pregnant again so i'm not sure if
abortion is i can't say that abortion is
a solution in that we have to be make
sure that we're responsible before that
because ultimately what happens is that
people are using mental health and of
course that that's a real thing but at
the same time
to if if you have mental health issues
because of it say it as it is
they're using it as a cop out you you're
pregnancies are going up and 35 and over
um abor sorry under 18 um abortions are
going down and over 35 and over
abortions are going up so women
have more abortions
and that does not that does not surprise
me because because abortion
abortion is hypergamy it's a girl saying
this isn't the best i can do i can do
better i'm sorry if a girl gets pregnant
by the nba player you can't pay her to
abort that shot
drake's drake's baby mama no amount of
money she's keeping that baby
that's why i don't like the tristan
tristan thompson's new baby room because
i always i always say this i'm like oh
my god she knew
what she was doing 100 tristan thompson
really yeah but that whole yeah but like
she
her her own argument which annoying i
don't even know what these people are
about jason thompson
chloe joey kardashian is my
nba player he's a cheer but basically he
had a situation where he was he was
cheating again obviously because that's
that's that's his thing yeah
he does that yeah
oh he's he like known for that yeah yeah
he's not he's known for sleeping yeah he
cheated he cheated with his baby mama's
sister's friend like little sister's
friend oh my gosh
but with this one
so reading the pinkish stuff cheating
with the friend
of the sun not jaded pinker the reason i
don't like this this specific one is
because her whole excuses are i didn't
know i could get pregnant right but then
as soon as you find that they were
having so much unprotected sex all the
time right or as much according to the
stories that were told by them okay and
then she finds out she's pregnant and
she keeps it i'm like all right fine
cool you want to do your own thing you
didn't know you had you didn't know you
could get pregnant i believe you up
until
she calls the baby tristan thompson's
last name the baby has tristan
thompson's last name right and so the
babies are thompson yeah of course that
jail is
out of wedlock right and he was in
another relationship so then you have to
ask the question why did you give the
kid
why'd you keep it no no no no no no no
no you're meant to take the time
exactly thank you but i'm saying let's
think one step further than it's her
choice why do you think a lady who
has no outside things outside of she was
a mother when she stepped with him would
give her child that she slept with on
cheating with an nba player why do you
think she would give him his last name
because that's the best show she can do
he's gonna yeah he's gonna set up he's
gonna set up that child
and it's a status symbol it's a status
like reasons for abortions and 98 of
abortions in the uk are under ground c
which is that the pregnancy has not
exceeded its 24th week and that the
continuance of the pregnancy would
involve greater risk greater than if the
pregnancy was terminated of the injury
to the physical
or mental health of the woman yes mental
illness yeah
yeah
do you know what you know what the these
like abortions yeah from for the
majority of people that have them are
traumatic yeah like when i when i speak
to individual people that have had
abortions they're not happy about have
about doing it they're regretting it so
so it it it's shocking to me when you
see those two girls and you see that
that girl so
passionate and excited about
the idea of having an abortion or having
a it seems to me like
both sides would agree that
you don't want an abortion
even the people that have an abortion
you don't want one
you don't want an abortion the people
that do
people don't agree with abortion they
also don't want abortions nobody wants
abortions however
so why are they so passionate sorry why
are they so passionate about about it
it's because it's because it's because
they're hoes they're in the streets what
the [ __ ] they want they want to sleep
around with no consequence what what
about the people yeah and that has to be
it because what are you saying over
there bro what about the people that
want to weigh up the options that you
can have someone that has to live with
the regret of having an abortion or
bringing up a child that you naturally
don't want to do
i mean they do
and they just don't care like modern
women are selfish not like modern
person yeah and that's the thing modern
women are all about me me me me me and
it's their soul
i'm gonna throw something into it do you
like
because people say you said something
amazing in that video pearl right for me
you said
guys stop allowing women to tell you
that you can't have an opinion
on something because normally when men
have an opinion on this women say oh
you're a man you're not allowed to say x
y and z they say no
so do you do
people think that men should have a say
when it comes to yes
yeah do you think they should absolutely
it's your child too they should an
opinion
yeah i think they should i think i think
they should have an opinion
but because we don't have an opinion
it's almost like
because because it's not out it's
it's not up to us it's not our choice at
all you're not carrying it yeah you're
not carrying it it's not it's not our
choice at all so so
that's the reason why we won't give an
appointment opinion at the time
at the time if it happens we won't
really get involved in it
at the end of the day we'll give our
like dude says look you can do what do
what you feel like is right yeah in that
situation because if you as a man say to
a woman to get an abortion and she wants
to child you come across as the bad
person no i've been interested
i've been in that situation before where
i just feel like as a guy like you
should be leading her and like you you
shouldn't care what she thinks so
so did you know like a piece of
anecdotal
evidence uh an adult story i was
actually with a woman
for years
and she got pregnant right
and you know making good money living in
a good place i was like okay cool
amazing yeah let's do this and she was
like nah i don't want it what can you do
and i was like
did you marry i was like what do you
mean
i was like what do you mean no no we
should we should have it and she was
like nah i don't want it now what was
interesting and something that is not
spoken about i think
is that
men who actually want the child
and women that don't want the child
and so a man what i had to do
is go along
because i didn't have the power
i didn't have i had to go along with
someone who wanted to kill my own child
yeah and then
she wanted me to nurse her through
the kids killing my own child and i'm
like
i wanted the child yeah so it's like
it's a very it's a very weird like
put in that place
to be put in that position
why did you stay with her
i'm just like but if i wanted that child
and you didn't and i thought there's no
there's no reason why we shouldn't have
it yeah why must i be put in a position
as a man to actually
allow someone to murder my child in my
eyes i believe this murder right to
murder my child and then have to nurse
you through that and be like oh my god
are you okay babe sorry good thing you
didn't marry my child good thing you
didn't marry did you have the
conversation beforehand in the sense of
before you got into this relationship
you spoke about children we were in we
were in
as far as i knew we were in a good space
right so we were together for a few
years right we were living together like
we had a whole thing go so i'm like okay
a child come in fine yeah however
i've spoken to other men also
that have been put in a position where
the woman that they're with
wants to get rid of the child yeah and
they want the child and i'm like when it
comes to that men's feelings don't get
taken into consideration yeah like men
are supposed to just allow a woman to
kill their child and just being born
with a very long 10 months though
because you think imagine she doesn't
want it you want you're happy all of
those 10 months and you have to just
watch her be unhappy for however long
but once that child comes you're not
unhappy
most of the time women don't change some
sounds no a lot of women
most women look at that child and think
how could i ever why
that's a very idealistic mindset that
you would love to think but that again
in reality it just isn't the case no but
can we be real i mean i mean some some
women hate their children
i genuinely believe that because they
think they like wish they didn't
reproduce with whoever they reproduce
that's right that's why i i see people
like their kids are like their handbag
almost it's very it's very weird they're
an accessory yeah it's a very weird
dynamic especially like when they'll
on instagram their ass will be all over
instagram and i'm just like you don't
you have like two kids at home so
they're clearly trying to like
but
i mean
like what that's what i'm saying like
modern women are selfish because they
care about themselves they care about
themselves more than the guy they're
with they care about themselves more
than they care about their own kids when
i asked her i said why why would you not
want this child
oh i'm doing this i'm doing that i want
to do that i want to do this and i'm
like well this is our this is not just
your child this is actually our child
and i say
you know my body my choice that whole
thing came into like you know interviews
because she could just have the child
and then give it to you that's not gonna
single fathers have singled fathers have
better outcomes than singing the mothers
yeah in a lot of ways that's the
non-selfish way of doing it yeah okay
look we'll have this but i don't want a
child i don't want to deal with it so
just look you deal with it and i'll just
but are you still somewhere
women aren't going to let you do that um
you don't have to put someone so that's
what they're saying now you're doing it
all by yourself yeah most people don't
want to
do it by yourself
why would you stay with someone who
would abort your child because she's
clearly saying i can do better yeah i
don't think it's a bit better sometimes
oh situation like no oh no no she
doesn't want you no i i promise you like
girl's point of view she is absolutely
saying she can do better because if that
is his nba players i don't care if she's
16 i don't care if she's 25 i don't care
if she's 35 i don't care if she's about
to be the partner in a law firm firm she
is keeping that kid what if he's just
about timing no no no i'm telling you
if that girl views you as the best that
she can do she is keeping that child the
only reason that she wouldn't keep it is
because she wants to market herself to
other guys whenever she's done using you
for your resources so whenever she's
whenever she's about to be out whenever
she's about to be out she'll show but
that's something i had to learn though
the thing is because you know when
you're young i'm 41. yeah but a lot of
people don't think i'm 41. i've lived a
couple of lives you know i mean i lived
a couple of lives but when you're young
and you don't know that you just think
oh i'm in love with this person and
we're fine
and it's like oh
like she had other plans like you know
when you come out like you had other
plans do you know what i mean like you
learn that as a as a man i guess as the
older you get and she said something as
well you're like how am i supposed to
allow you to have an abortion you did
not allow her i didn't think the the
babies in her body there was nothing you
could do all you could do is just plead
your case and pray
but when you say allow her like honestly
i've been in that situation before where
all i could have said away yes
a woman did get pregnant and all i could
say is look at the end of the day it is
your whatever is whatever i can't i
don't really have a say in this so
whatever i say
is is irrelevant because at the end of
the day you're going to do what you want
to do so i'm just going to give it all
to you and a lot of ways that can seem
like you're just pushing it on her but
at the end of the day that is true what
other choice do you have you don't have
any you're you're back against is
against the wall in that situation so
that was the situation i was in you know
you don't want to have like a
conversation with her and like lead her
yeah but if she decides
no i understand i understand like
legally you have no rights like i'm with
you i think it's actually i think it's
wrong
but like
if you're in a relationship with someone
doesn't she follow you typically in your
leadership
no not today not in these days sometimes
this is the third year
i follow my husband one at a time
sorry i follow my husband i'm married
obviously what if he says jump i'll say
how high how down do you know what i
mean i bet you don't i promise i do
i promise i do but
like i even get told i get told off for
listening to my husband too often
right you know what i mean this is 2022.
and i know honestly i feel like us women
would be given too much but i'm saying
like you shouldn't deal with girls like
that like
because of a girl have you i'm sure at
some point no i'm saying like at some
point have you had a girl that's
obsessed with you she's doing whatever
the hell you say yeah yeah you guys are
all smiling
you're like
she's doing no it's not
in my situation
it was
it was early days
so it was it was too early to really
yeah
you just were fully yeah
in a thing we were yeah we were together
but it's not it wasn't it was very early
days you know what i mean so it's it's
not like we were
four years in and it's like and then i'm
you know i would definitely be having a
conversation like right now weren't you
scared to lay down with her in early
days without a conor what if she had
something
without jerusalem i'm gonna put you on a
spot like that early days you lay down
with her no no protection
what if she had something it's like
it's like
okay
it's like it's like you it's it's like
it's like you lay a piece of meat in
front of a bunch of lions you make sure
you you lay a piece of meat a bunch of a
frog
in front of a bunch of lions they're
eating the thing yeah but it's the type
of thing
it's the type of it's the type of person
because you know like not every like
there's a type of person who who's gonna
is gonna burn you in that ways yeah i
mean
i think burn you yeah that's the type of
person that's gonna burn you in that way
so i i was what type of
with the person i was with i wasn't
worried about that side of things you
know i mean yeah because there's a you
only you only
associate with certain types
because you didn't know really know her
like that yes
i mean
i'm not talk i'm not talking about uh
like no i'm throwing i'm not talking
about one month in like i'm talking
about maybe like four or five months you
would know you would you would you would
know what the situation is so did you
not think after
this for me
like personal responsibility for the
decision of you knowing that if you're
going to have sex with somebody that
that comes you know what
you know what men are not exempt from
from the the accountability of of that
decision however women
women
have all of the power so at the end of
the day you you it's your choice yeah
what happens i'm not going to say i'm
not going to say i wasn't careless
yes
yeah well look yeah it is careless
because you know that if you if you if
you have sex you you can you know and
you you do you ejaculate inside you you
can come so do you feel comfortable
partly responsible for the murder of
that child or for the death of that
child i don't i wouldn't pull that out
yes that's where i would feel
responsible because
it took two to make that choice you know
what i would say i would say i would say
yes and that's me being as cow
accountable as possible as possible i
would say yes
not a good situation i wouldn't do it
again
do you know what i mean but
at the end of the day it wasn't my
choice
for
it wasn't my choice i felt like i was an
accomplice
an accomplice
to like like when i looked back and i
felt like i was unaccomplished to like
some murder or something
do you guys ever think about like like
the kid
like do you ever i think i think about
my childhood yeah he's talking about it
right now i think about a child all the
time i think oh what if i had that child
what the yeah
yeah but the thing is like i said it was
out of my hands because it was like it
got to a point where
you know it became it became a bit testy
yeah you know i mean and i'm like
seriously like this is what you get yeah
this is what i want to do i'm like you
know what okay cool so my question is to
you my bro um
do you think that if you had from the
jump and i know it was early days so i
understand that you didn't understand
this was this was years this was years
ago i'm just yeah don't worry about that
your friend's not judging you yeah i've
been this question my girlfriend knows
about this
but we we talked right all right
but
i'm talking about this was years ago so
the question is do you think that if you
had set like the president to say this
is what i expect this is what i want i
want this kid i want that and i know
you're saying it wasn't your choice but
if you had stabbed your authority to say
this is where i am and then she had made
the decision after she knew where you
stood
do you think it would have been
different
i don't know i don't know okay is the
answer to that you know what with that
ish i think a lot of people do not
get into relationships and
they ask the most frivolous questions
yeah people are in relationships and
they don't even know where their partner
stands on politics don't know where
their partner stands on abortion they
don't know these things like and they
just kind of work it out as they go
along i think people should be
nowadays i think they should be more um
forthright and let their partners know
this is where i stand on this it's right
on that you see where i stand on racism
so i stand on i don't know um abortion i
think people should do that more
nowadays and they don't they say oh
what's your favorite color yeah don't
worry about that yeah i think don't
worry about that dude don't you see
relate sorry do you want to yeah
i was going to say i think it's how you
see like relationships as well like if
you see a relationship as a partnership
so if for example if i get pregnant i'm
not assuming it's not my husband like my
husband has a say in this whether
whether i'm christian or not like my
husband has a say in what happens to me
or or in my body or in my decisions and
in my choices so i think it also defines
it depends on how do we actually see
relationships and is this person a
partner or is it a partner until
i i'm pregnant or is it a partner am i
on my own have we kind of put ourselves
in a box where it's like actually i just
i i actually do want to be my own person
i don't actually want to have some sort
of
relationship that relies on one another
and i'm actually just
when it comes to me it's just about me
if that if that makes sense yeah i think
like i said before i think um
i think
women in relationships do things for
their happiness um yeah whatever makes
her happy and men in relationships do
everything's for the woman's happiness
that's that's what i want and
unfortunately that is the way things go
yeah and that is i don't think it should
be that way not me but i think that men
are always trying to make women happy
and women are always trying to show
themselves
men built the world
men built the world
for women to just [ __ ] on them right in
the world that they built and say men
are trash they built a society that's
safe there's no wars we have the police
to protect us
and yet we we can go on birth control we
can if we're homeless there's women's
shelters
if we get pregnant we can get an
abortion we get bailed out of every bad
decision and yet they still complain
about that you know what's funny today
actually
today well for the past three days my in
my apartment my my bathroom has been
being fixed right so there's a bunch of
men in there and my house looks like a
bombsite right so
but it's a bunch of men doing it right
and i looked at those men doing it and i
was like damn i couldn't see women doing
this
like they're literally they're taking
out drywall they're doing all of that
and i'm like
i'm like i'm not saying women can't do
it yeah right but i'm saying no no they
can't no i think some candy no no no no
no no no no
but carry on let me tell you i'm not
saying women can't do it but when i'm
watching men do this and i'm like this
is the fabric of society yeah this is
what gets stuff done yeah and for women
to be you know abusing men [ __ ] on
men saying men men ate [ __ ] man i'm just
like you know what if all those men said
you know what yeah we're
trash we're [ __ ] we're not doing this no
more women would like they wouldn't know
what to do but that's what's happening
though no with this i'm i'm going into
very very watery territory go for it
that is what's happening now
can i ask you a question because men are
becoming
feminized now
agreed
so it's happening i mean and in some in
some cases us when we really have
ourselves to blame sometimes like when
my husband comes in in the morning so he
works night shifts
and he has to come here for rest he's
helping me with the kids i actually
asked him i'm like you promise you're
not going to go mad on me so if you got
mad at me right now you have a mental
breakdown i don't know what i'm going to
do
whereas i've been allowed to have a
mental breakdown yeah you know i mean
i've had i've had that before at work
and i came home and you know i mean he
held the kids he did everything
you know like honestly um i'm standing
i'm gonna
be on this platform and actually give
you like your flowers you lot don't like
flowers do you okay
thank you
you know i was on i was on the elizabeth
line
um that's how i got here and you know
you just look at a woman did not do that
a woman couldn't do it yeah they never
built the train they never bought the
the underground don't get me wrong maybe
we've helped here and there with food
maybe bringing the stuff but actually
building it we don't have the power and
that's why when they taught me when they
talk about women being oppressed it's
it's wrong it's not correct how will we
oppress women we didn't have to fight in
wars we didn't have to do the hard jobs
men protected us throughout all of human
history the only reason we couldn't vote
is because it came with me the
responsibility of being drafted that's
why feminism from the beginning has
always been freedom without the
responsibility it's a set up most women
didn't even want the right to vote
and it's this narrative that that is
trying to wage a gender war so we don't
build families anymore
i get so frustrated at women saying that
they can be men
oh they're not they're different kinds
of people
when men were doing our men do all of
this stuff right all of this
the dirty stuff that women don't want to
do right for you to come and look at me
as a man and say oh yeah i can be
know you you cannot not
with me
there's no way but quickly quickly can i
just say something yeah the two women
obviously you are both married yeah yeah
if you look wanted to have the child and
your husbands didn't what would be your
stance on it
if if i wanted to have a child and my
husband didn't
it's him because you said that you
listened to your husband that's a crazy
situation
why is that impossible possible
one at a time one at a time big man
married you know what i know you know
honestly this is i'm actually going to
speak on a doctor um
yeah and if my husband's watching right
now we had um two kids the age
difference between them is 14 months
and he was like right
i am not going to go mad in this country
so go and get an iud i didn't want to go
and get an iud um you wanted more
children yeah i didn't mind the girl but
like i'm a teacher i'm trying to you
know i mean have kids
help the population you know
population but he asked me to go get an
iud
and i did
now he thinks he's ready he's like okay
go take it out i'm too comfortable i
don't want to take it out now do you
know what i mean i'm too comfortable now
you're not listening you want another
child now
i don't i i don't know where he started
i don't know
because i would have had my fourth by
now it seemed like every bloody i was
pregnant have some more i have nine
siblings it's the siblings it's the best
gift oh i have nine on my death side oh
yeah yeah i have nine on my dad's side
five on my mom's side it's like ten best
friends i love it
yeah i don't like any of my siblings
okay well you know you can't
can't work out for
that was him so like if he was so he
said he didn't want to have any no
child but he's not he doesn't want it
exactly so i listen to him when he's
ready
you know then we try everything for
whatever you took it out you took out
you know it's still still known we're
still in but i will take our next hubby
where's hubby
where's it at home with our children
whilst i'm here
let me talk to you right now brother
she gonna take out just keep pushing bro
i wanna have five we agreed five but now
no we agreed to have five and now he's
saying no we're gonna stop at three i'm
gonna take him to court
i'm taking him to court because the
agreement when we got married we're
gonna have five now he's saying he wants
to have three he's going to court
so what do you what do you do then if if
he generally says no no more
i'll get pregnant what's his choice see
there we go wow there we go
he has no choice and he's going to help
me look after those kids all right
financially spiritually and physically i
hope they're all going to be his yeah
what do you mean all right just checking
i'm married we don't i'm not like
do you
do you think that paternity um
sorry do you think that like dna test
should be mandatory yes
yes
yes yes yes yes yes that is trifling
yeah i'm tired you know what's funny a
lot of people that say oh no it
shouldn't be other people with two or
three potential baby ducks yeah daddy's
every single time they've had this issue
it's like why wouldn't you because
because my feelings will get hurt okay
so your feelings might get hurt for a
day
yeah his pockets will be hurt for 80.
i have a question if a woman does
paternity fraud should she go to jail
for the amount of time
i give her double yeah
maybe maybe not double okay when you say
double go down
that's why like um supports like 100 or
150 dollars a month
no i'm saying like if if he spent the
last five years raising that kid
putting his time energy resources
five years he can't get back yeah then
yeah you should serve 10.
because he because he served fives or at
minimum she should be fined she should
have to pay or like be a court order to
pay everything back and it should be a
fine because going sending her to jail
in that situation is going to remove a
mother no because if a guy goes if a guy
doesn't pay child support he can go
straight yeah
it's interesting how there's always an
innate and it's always from men like an
innate protection of women because
they're like they're like no we can't we
can't send him to jail yeah you're right
but yeah it's like but there's still a
woman yeah okay have you seen that all
right have you seen the story um i
forgot what it was on of the guy who um
he didn't pay child support went to jail
for five five years came out did a
paternity test
i think the thing though with the whole
paternity testing maybe because i'm just
coming from a different perspective if
relationships are built on trust right
you know i can't no no no
roman i can't imagine my husband coming
to me saying you need to do a paternity
test yes to prove that i because i i
think ultimately it's built on trust in
an ideal world of course
people who cheat because people lie
because people are dishonest the reason
why we have paternity tests where we
have lie detector tests why we have dna
that's the reason why these things came
about
i haven't i haven't agree i have an
agreement with my girlfriend right yeah
that any time for whatever reason maybe
hormones whatever she was out and she
wants to look through my phone i've said
to her this is a deal that we make if
you find nothing you owe me money
i've said this to her we shook on it so
every time she she gets a bit like oh my
god
it hasn't happened what if you're very
good at hiding i'm gonna have to try
that one uh why i feel very good at how
much money no i just want to know it's
25 per look in it so that's 25 per app
so
if you want to go instagram that's 25
and find nothing go on snapchat find
nothing 25.
go on what's up five nothing that's
another 25. i feel like that should just
be shut down anyway amanda she shouldn't
be doing she should touch it
relationships
but like one at a
time but like paul and and gray was
saying
if you give people boundaries they're
not gonna push it she never she never
asked me to look for my phone because
she knows i'm not cheating and for
whatever reason if you think i am cool
put your money where your mouth is
yeah it's an interesting concept i guess
because why would i want someone who's
always just stressed out and looking
through my phone and thinking looking
over her shoulder a lot of demons aren't
there so does she have the potential to
to do that
everyone what about if you want to go
through your phone same thing
so if you like we're going to cheat on
each other it'll be very very expensive
it's very expensive very easy now if you
find it if you find anything then if you
find it yeah
yeah it'll be very easy if you have to
pay to get cheated
[Laughter]
you always money [ __ ]
it goes from twitter
people hide [ __ ] but like there's only
so much you can do i just feel like it's
i don't know it's out of your control if
someone wants to cheat on you they're
going to cheat on you and you either
find out or you don't because i've never
been the one
the one thing you learn
when you think people you think they
haven't got time to cheer me yeah people
they probably have time actually sorry
who's are you the oldest one here yeah
okay
in your experience does the truth come
out eventually when it comes to cheating
for men and for women both it comes out
i disagree it could take years yeah
women
i'm saying if you're still together
yeah yeah right because
both partners at some point in time
can feel an energy shift
like it doesn't matter it doesn't matter
like you know if you you're you're
married right yeah you know your
partner's and you know you know you know
what he does everything every day you
know his movements
you can feel a shift and be like that's
a bit yeah different right because
my last relationship was ten years i
might as well be married but
yeah i'm saying okay i i knew the
logistics of someone you know and they
knew my logistics so if the logistics
got
started going a little bit funny like
either of us
oh you didn't
explain and when would you say it was
the same with like friends of yours that
have cheated or like men women both ways
does it catch up to them eventually do
you know if it if people don't find out
um
tell them i think i think it it might
catch up with you at some point that's
what like that was my feeling because i
just feel like you can't run from
yourself and at some point and at some
point your habits catch up to you and
like if you're going to be married for
40 50 years what are the odds that you
keep it a secret the whole time you know
what's so weird though yeah some people
don't actually find out until that
they've passed like at the funeral but
that's still there that's for men that's
for men
i mean like that's still like i know
people that have gone to funerals and
found siblings yeah do you know what i
mean but that's it's still catching up
yeah
there's only so long you can hide from
the truth yeah and so even so that's
your legacy and if you don't if you
don't some people don't care they're
like whatever the whole yeah
and another thing as well that i feel a
lot of people don't pay attention to
especially women that are married and be
cheating on their husbands
when a woman cheats on their husband
i don't know maybe call me superstitious
or whatever
but
what i've seen in the past is them like
the man he's just not normal his stuff
starts messing up
finally
like
like a woman cheating on her husband you
mess him up
sorry you mess him up
physically spiritually for like uh
financially
if he finds out not just when he finds
out when you start doing it
it happens
that's not that's that's why they say
when a woman cheats it's it's if it's
more dangerous than a man
it is but when a man cheese oh oh he's
cheating
oh no because a man can because a man's
cheating is not emotional it's not
emotional one and secondly
now a woman's cheated you're sleeping
with these two men unprotected you get
pregnant whose baby is it do not mean
it's not natural
it's not natural for a woman to cheat on
her husband so you bring all this bad
luck yeah
baggage on your husband i have a
question would you guys stay with your
husbands if um he stepped out yeah oh
sorry
she said no she said no hesitation
how many times i'm leaning more towards
yes
i i think mainly because
i there i feel like there's a strong
theme of forgiveness
and i'm not i'm not saying that that
justifies you you cheating but i i would
hope that there is something in within
myself that could offer forgiveness now
if you're a serial cheater then yeah how
many hall passes
there's no it's not about hall passes
it's just you both just gave them away
it's the it's the element of forgiveness
i think this probably comes from faith
right you you have to
there is an element of forgiving that is
important for our marriage anyway the
the element of forgiveness we don't hold
grudges we don't hold that i'm not
saying that it's okay for him to cheat
but what i'm saying is that forgiveness
is a key value in our marriage as long
as he's still treating you as his wife
wait so what about you what if um
there's more women than men in this
world i'm saying like is unlimited he
could cheat as many times as long as
it's not emotional you don't care as
long as he's doing it he's coming back
to you right he's coming back to me and
i don't have the misses and let's let
you know what we're all
obviously where we come from
historically men married two three
four well what is it because thousand
years ago it won eight thousand years
ago yeah
he's backing up what you're saying where
you said it was 2-3 and he's saying 8
000 years ago it was even further where
it was 17 for everyone
and how long did he live
don't worry about that
well it was because of rulers and
emperors like gangas khan i think would
you know mess up the distribution
because they would have hundreds of them
in me yeah so i don't know what it was
for the average guy but but 40 of you
you're correct 40 of men have reproduced
historically where 80 80 to 90 percent
of women have
there's a um called out of eden
um by a guy called uh
david
barash don't i think his name is barash
but he was saying that prior to
like the western
one-man one yes right
most cultures
were living in some kind of poliginous
or polygamous
um relationship so that's what we have
been doing more so than this one man
one woman thing this thing is this
i have a question for the guys so
out of your friends that maybe had a
whole face like slept around for a while
and then stopped
could they actually
long term actually
you guys are pretty young so i guess the
best question this is for sarah long
term does the guy actually stop because
to me it's like your habits are who you
are so if a dude spent 10 years sleeping
around what are the odds he can remain
faithful to his wife it depends on his
nature okay go ahead so um
i can only go by my nature right
my nature is
i've been in three long-term
relationships
seven years
two and a half years and then ten years
right so
what's that what that's showing me is
that my nature is to be with a companion
right
but there are some men who have never
been in like any long-term relationship
do you know what i mean and so their
nature
is to just
have sex with whatever they can have sex
with so i think it depends on the man's
nature and i think even when i can i can
hold my hand up a bit like even when i
was in long-term relationships i was i'd
looked at women thinking i had the urge
and i had the chance right to do it and
i was like nah nah i can't but
that resides in all men
yeah i think i think that urge resides
in all men doesn't matter whether your
nature is to be with one person or i
think that nature to have animals as
well yeah yeah i think that nature
a man can have sex with more than one
person i think it resides i think that
if i think that if women really
uh respected
the sacrifice it took it actually takes
a man to
to um to go to to
stray away from his nature and focused
solely on her then maybe it'll be a lot
easier to to to do that because there's
she she understands like wholeheartedly
that is that is a
you're going against your nature as a
human to to to to remain here does that
make sense i don't think this is a
male nature is respected as much as
female nature like for instance
like
we we always talk about when a woman's
on her period and what and what you know
hormonal changes and and what we must do
and how we must be sensitive and stuff
like that but when we're talking about a
male nature it's almost like
well you can't you can't but you can't
just keep it in your in your pants
it's almost like
you're marginalizing our our
our expression our nature as men do you
know what i mean at the end of the day
and it's and it's as you said it's only
been recent times when this is
uh
like it hasn't been monogamy is very
recent yeah it is the recent question
for the majority of history
we've been
we've been kind of
able to to spread our seed a little bit
a little bit wider do you know what i
mean so i have another question have you
ever been in a relationship where the
girl turns you down for sex and is it
frustrating when you're trying to be
monogamous with her and yet she won't
say yes to sex
see that doesn't that that's what
doesn't make sense to me like that like
how can you if you're the person who's
supposed to be
uh keeping me monogamous
why would you deny it why would you deny
the the the
this is this is you sometimes
sometimes that's the trap because they
want you to go elsewhere
do you think yeah nothing's just self
entitled you reckon
some girls settle with guys yeah i agree
with you so i think some girls try to
get like
guys to cheat or get them to like
they'll pick fights so they don't
because a lot of girls are
non-confrontational so they don't want
to be the one to dump you so they'll try
to they'll try to like argue with you
until you dump them or like make your
life hell until you dump them well
patrice o'neill said
generally women
want to know a man can fish
right
and if he's caught her as a fish
the reason why she was attracted to him
is because he was a fisherman he was
able to find him right he wasn't able to
fish and
and and the minute you show him your
woman that you're no longer able to fish
she doesn't really like you anymore
you see the thing is the the time that
that happened to me is kind of different
to those stories because you turned out
to be gay so
wait what
the hell
what happened
[Music]
yeah sex was being withheld it was going
down whatever she cheats on me with this
guy fine what i don't mean fine
emotionally or
she did what she did when i say fine i'm
just saying it's like it's what it is
like walk through yeah i'm fine i'm over
there and i'm over that now fine cool so
then she she moves from him to this girl
comes out as gay and is now engaged to
this girl oh
yeah but she still banged the guy though
oh i actually i spy i have a theory i
have a theory about girls that do that
go on i don't
say it this is a little offensive to you
in this situation i would not get but i
promise
i have this theory that girls will
become gay because they can't get the
guys they want and they would rather
they would rather marry a girl than
marry a betta in their eyes
i have heard that before like so that's
why you see girls like they kind of
become gay around their like epiphany
phase because they're like
or you know when the wall has like on
the other end of the wall because
they're like oh the guys that i want
don't want me anymore so i'm gonna just
go back but then piggybacking off of
that is that this society is
women have made men better
do you know what i mean like the
feminist movement has made men more
feminine and so i've said before like
for women to make men more feminine and
then be upset that men are more feminine
it's very weird it's like you be more in
touch your emotional side you know you
know talk to me like my girlfriends talk
to me all of this kind of stuff is that
you're making this man into a woman and
then when he is you're like
excuses
i don't like that it's like you know
that's why i said men should be men half
the time to be honest and i'm talking as
a woman we women sometimes really don't
know what you want oh no i'm gonna say
as it is we don't know what we what we
want sometimes we'd be sleeping with
this man but we're both dreaming
different
we want a guy with
like you want a guy with with dress i
wanna you're making him put extensions
in his head no no
no no no i'm talking no because actually
a basketball player um i was on this
page and we're talking about
um like how we're feminizing men you
know what i mean he's i forgot his name
jimmy butler yeah but now he's got he's
got faux locs and that's a woman yeah
it's a woman it's a woman's thing a man
can grow his own hair naturally you know
what i mean he's got he's got yeah
grow his own hair naturally
he's got hoop earrings in his ears and
everything where
he's being feminine yeah faux locs on a
man is crazy you know i mean like you
can grow that naturally that's
unacceptable processing unacceptable
unacceptable the thing is
my husband's got to read and he was like
should i make it i'm like no no no no no
i like it the only pushback i can give
you to that is the fact that jimmy
butler did that to himself isn't
something that everyone's like oh my god
whoa everyone in the nba world is
getting on to this guy is it like i
would agree with you if it was a thing
was like oh my god yeah everyone's just
saying he's looking fantastic if you go
through nba twitter or instagram and
look at the comments underneath the
phone it's all like what the [ __ ] is on
his head
look at the top of his head because
people are waking up now we're seeing
that this is not this is not funny
anymore do you know what i mean people
are waking up that's why now men think
it can be women and women think they can
be mended we don't even know what a man
yeah we don't even know what one is
anymore
yeah i should do super chats and then we
should probably close out the show yeah
it's been two hours it's twelve yeah
it's maybe twelve yeah i think it's been
more than two hours okay
guys thank you so much for the super
chats um all of the super chats are
going towards new equipment and our new
studio guys i've been looking at some
places they're pretty lit we're gonna
we're gonna do a bunch of different
content it's gonna be so cool so if you
guys have something specific that you
would like to see changed or something
new in the studio let me know in the
comments um okay 90 free toe pet frito
pie in france it's illegal for men to
ask for a paternity test
you posted about the 70-year divorce on
insta a man with a broken spirit who can
handle proverbs silly sausage
women are not oppressed men always try
to help you if we wanted to oppress you
it wouldn't take long look at
afghanistan it took three days to put
you back in the kitchen please
appreciate the men
90 free toe pie lady in the brown
cover your legs please
neo moss
pearl speaking on baby mothers looking
at the story in louisiana about a single
mother taking her children's lives and
the
boys survived and the girl didn't make
it she was losing the custody battle sad
story 90 frito pie beta le jessie lee
peterson happy
happy you know him too britt cormier the
problem with grape is the exception if
legal only if it is legal only in cases
of grape and the woman falsely reports
grape to get an abortion the dna from
the child can be used to track the
father and he might get charged with
grape even though it was consensual sky
shepherd i'm a mixed race american i'm
adopted my birth mother
i'm adopted my birth mother mother was
14. i grew up loving home in a loving
home i served my country and i'm
following my dreams i am not a number
and neither are the other babies 90
frito pie what's to stop women from
aborting babies of a specific race my
body's my choice right reddit has pages
on breeders get off
get off on getting pregnant and then
abort oh god um chris z for all of you
desperate scammers out there here is
pearl's number 1 800 no chance you're
welcome
look at that okay i shall just keep
going um you're well you're welcome by
the way pearl andrew tate does a uk
based podcast all the time get him all
the pr on the pregame i've been trying
y'all go spam his chat and spam sneako's
chat too i want to get both of them on
the show
yeah yes please um steven with aj there
is no red yellow black white we are all
brown hashtag one race equality begins
with the womb laura lawrence block does
the panel realize just by saying
abortion is is murder if they were u.s
people they would call them trump
supporters white joe dussy i like
turtles um lp
when you use terms like not on paper
you're basically ghost hunting when you
have actual facts and statistics to back
up an argument i read that one already
okay i think that's all the super chats
i'm gonna um
refresh it really quick guys like the
video a like is free that's the number
one metric that youtube uses to push out
these lives so if you've enjoyed this
live like the video okay silly sausage
if two eagles make a baby and two
sparrows make it baby
what makes no baby two swallows
missing 44.
um the other guy's still beat though
okay
good good okay i'm on that note oh here
goes go ahead
um all right we're gonna close out the
show now uh thank you all for um tuning
in
uh thank you everyone here for
contributing um i think as we close out
we'll just go around and just get final
thoughts from this one anyway you want
to speak your piece down peace on
anything go now um
yeah i think thus in terms of abortions
i think
everyone kind of does have the right to
have just make that decision if they do
want to have an abortion or not
um
obviously just be a bit more cautious
with certain decisions that you make but
i definitely feel like it shouldn't be
banned
okay um
as for abortions please please please
ladies
can we please be careful with who we lay
down with if you know you don't want to
have a child with this person
please have sex with unprotected
thank you
red line is a chicken in the egg
situation so to say that one thing is
trump in the other is to dismiss the
other side of it i want to say that for
a while but the conversation moved on
from there
um i would say that abstinence is an
option
i think you you can we can control
ourselves there is something called
self-control and i think that is
important and also something we said
earlier we were talking about
men being trash a little bit offensive i
remember this poem i wrote a couple of
years ago and the line was but if men
are trash then our wounds the dumpster
trucks god threw them in
and um
that's a whole another conversation
that's good
that's good but that's where i'm going
to leave it
you should you should
come back and read the poem yeah
i'm happy
um i think uh
it takes it takes a number of years to
like when we're talking about studies it
takes a number of years to collate a
nice you know a nice uh
conclusion when it comes to to studies i
think that the the data is in
uh when it comes to abortion and stuff
like that i think that it's been misused
based on based on the information that's
out there it's been misused there needs
to be some sort of
rejig reform and rethinking of the whole
of of what we're doing here and i think
that's what uh that's what will happen
now at the moment now when when they've
changed the you know especially in
america where you know the conversation
started because of the change back to
how it was
i think it's it's gonna move the
conversation forward and maybe there'll
be a little bit people will be a bit
more thoughtful about uh actions
um i'd just like to say that um
because we're here in the uk and we
don't have the whole trump you know
biden thing um
this conversation
is not a polarized
conversation based on
who you support right it's a
conversation based on facts statistics
figures
feelings opinions right so yeah for the
american audience we're not all trump
supporters okay we just have different
opinions and um i'd just like to say
yeah um
can we stop killing black babies please
yes
um
follow me on
follow me on instagram all of the links
are in the description
pal
okay guys um
final final announcements i'm just going
to go through the ones i went through in
the beginning follow our clips channel
we want to get it to 10k subs you guys
have been awesome you literally got it
to 10k almost in a week so let's get
there also subscribe to the main channel
i'm going to be tortured at 250k because
i said i would do a 24-hour live stream
so if you want to see me tortured for 24
hours again last time i did an ice
bucket challenge and i questioned my
entire life so if you enjoyed that sign
up round two subscribe to the channel
also sign up for our memberships that
goes towards our rent next year
there are four tiers of memberships and
at the top tier you can actually get a
one-on-one call with me every month um
subscribe like the video follow my
instagram just dot pearly things um also
just you wanna come in here who's our
member of the week
let's go jess just get your ways
come here
[Music]
oh oh oh oh you pressed something
jess came
and broke the storm
[Laughter]
just tell them who the member of the
week is
um
the member of the week is drumroll
please
zentius
nice
thanks for breaking it jessica yeah i
don't know we're almost done we love you
anyway jess
um also if you want to come on the show
message eddie the link is in the
description to his instagram
guys um it's only if you live in london
we're not we're not having random people
on the show from around the world if you
want to travel to london and come on the
show that's cool let eddie know the best
way to come on is if you bring your guy
you bring girls because guys are easy to
recruit for girls are harder so
subscribe to the channel like the video
and we will talk to you next time
take care people
we out
okay
[Music]
yo power cup
[Music]
this will be the reason why the members
need to donate for a new studio it
actually looks pretty good in the dark
it actually looks pretty good in the
dark it's not that bad yeah
yeah not on camera
yeah no no it's all right
yeah look you know your guardians